will be gone.
Oh my God.
It's so good.
That's not really Brian.
That's Jamie.
What does Brian,
Brian's a off doing the Kevin Pereira podcasts.
Hello Party people.
What the fuck?
This episode of the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by
audible.com.
If you go to audible.com,
forward slash Joe,
that's audible.com.
Forward Slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book or 30 free days of auto service with me are two
very smart guys who I'm sure are smart enough to know that audio books are the
shit.
It's a great way to take them a foundation.
Yeah,
but if you don't know about it,
go to audible.com and get yourself a free audio book.
I recommend the war of art by Steven Pressfield,
an excellent book on overcoming procrastination when it comes to artwork and
doing things and not just whoa,
no phone,
no computer.
Everybody's good
it.
Um,
it's an excellent way of commuting.
It's my favorite thing for audio books.
It's the best because otherwise you're stuck in your car and it sucks.
I was stuck in my car on the way over here and I was listening to an audio book
and it was fucking bad ass.
Um,
use like I got like I said,
uh,
odd.
Well Tom Ford Slash Joe,
use that website and get yourself one free book and 30 free days of honorable
service includes like there's podcasts on there and uh,
the opiate Anthony Radio shows on there,
which is the shit.
So,
uh,
go get yourself.
Some were also spawn,
we're also sponsored by legal zoom and a legal zoom is if you do some stupid
shit and now you can't,
don't do it that way.
Legal Zoom is,
uh,
is a lot of shit that you go to a lawyer for.
That's really annoying.
And a would basically it is,
is uh,
you know,
things like if you want to incorporate and become an LLC,
that shit takes,
it's a huge pain in the ass.
You got to talk to some dude,
you have to go somewhere and give some guy who has knowledge of all this shit,
a lot of money.
And it's annoying as fuck you.
You don't want to meet with somebody with a tie exact a Mundo son.
Yeah.
Cops might be waiting for you.
Some duties worth like 500 bucks an hour.
For what?
What do you,
what's going on here?
What are you protecting me from?
Why is it so complicated?
Legal Zoom is not a law firm.
Now.
They provide self help services at your specific direction.
So they also can connect you with an independent attorney if you need additional
guidance.
Like if you like,
oh,
this sucks.
I don't know what the fuck I'm doing.
Let me get a professional in here.
They'll connect you with an independent attorney.
Uh,
but it's really easy for things like LLCs or a,
if you want to make a will.
Um,
you know,
there's a lot of things that you could do online and uh,
do it far cheaper than you would if you went to an attorney.
And if you use a code name,
Rogan,
you'll save yourself even swap money.
Uh,
we're also brought to you by [inaudible] dot com that's o,
n n,
I,
t.
The,
a new gorilla kettle bells or in a,
if you haven't seen him.
Oh my God,
that looks so the,
the,
the fucking coolest thing ever.
Some guy was like,
as soon even practical,
like shut up.
Stupid.
Of course it's not practical.
Life is not all about being practical.
God dammit.
You got to have some cool looking shit,
man.
Like to see that as a piece of evidence in a criminal trial.
Sometimes a man would like himself,
a gorilla kettle bell.
Look at her face on that mother fucker.
I think that's you.
I need one of those in my life.
So look at that.
You as a monkey motivates you to work out,
doesn't it?
You look at,
that's it.
That's how I feel.
I,
I know I'm dead fucking scared man.
I want to lift weights quickly.
I want to get strong as fuck when I see that face.
That's funny face.
He has to get shit out of me.
Motivational Macy was lifting in American beauty.
It's a really awesome gorilla face.
The dude,
the dude who did it,
I again,
I have to get that information from Aubrey.
I'll,
I'll get to the artist's name because they're fucking wicked.
The chimpanzee,
which is 35 pounds,
and the gorilla,
which is 72 pounds.
I liked the word enlarged.
Yeah,
that's,
they have big fat cock candles.
And the reason being is that the,
the wider handles are harder to hold onto.
So it makes it more difficult to work for grip better.
It would,
I could lift that thing once with two hands.
That would be the under my workout.
Well,
you just,
if you wouldn't start with that anyway,
but you could do it.
Anybody can do kettle bells.
The beautiful thing about kettlebells,
it's,
it's a pretty natural human movement and when you do a lot of them,
it really connects to athletics,
whether it's a martial art or,
you know,
and I think anything you would do,
and I think rock climbing,
I think anything,
I think what kettle bells do is it strengthens your entire body as a unit.
It's a Russian system.
They developed it.
Those bad motherfuckers.
Oh Man.
All gangster.
Well they figured out some wild shit with this kettle bell cause the shape of
it,
you know,
and if there's never been a more versatile tool for fitness and in my opinion
you can get so much done and you could burn yourself out with one 35 pound
kettle bell.
That sounds so girl.
Like you tell like a real manly man football player type dude at the gym that
you can work out with 35 pounds and they'd be like,
what the fuck you talking about?
You kick is huge with 35 pounds.
I crap.
Right foot pounds.
I was doing this workout once and this,
uh,
this dude actually said that to me because I can't believe how little you're
lifting.
I was like,
God damn dude,
it's not about the amount.
How much lips?
I'm going to say he was a child,
move his arms,
his giant man.
He had leg,
arms,
legs,
the size of legs and just ridiculous.
I had to ride in the car with a guy like that.
He had to shuffle steer.
Yeah,
he was a football player.
He was a college football player.
The students was very friendly.
Goddamn.
He was just ridiculously huge and I,
here's how I was working out with 50 pounds,
50 pound dumbbell.
I have this whole workout like circuit that I do like this.
This is hard,
not a small thing.
Bust your ass with one.
If you know what you're doing and you have a series of things and you don't
rest,
there's,
there's a bunch of shit you could do with a 50 pound dumbbell cleans.
If you did like a series of cleans,
presses and chin ups with a or a pushups with them and,
and you know,
squats with them and just kept going like rep after rep after rep if you,
you know,
if you can work out with a 50 pound kettle bell like you can,
you can get a serious work on it and you can get like a real light heart attack
ready to die,
ready to shit your pants work out.
That's my better half 50 pound kettlebell one with the gorilla face on it.
Exactly.
Use the code name Brogan and you can save 10% off any and all the supplements,
uh,
including the delicious hemp force protein.
That's hemp force is beautiful because of two things.
One,
because it does taste delicious.
It's like the most high quality Hampton,
we could find any,
we have a rom Makkah and a raw cocoa.
So it's,
it's,
it's really like a delicious flavor.
It's also,
um,
it's um,
sweetened with Stevia,
so it's not sugar.
There's no,
there's like less than one gram or less sugar per serving and then that's just
natural from the hemp hemp itself.
It's really delicious stuff and really good for you.
And we can't even grow it in America.
We have to buy this shit from Canada.
They have to buy it from Canada.
We're in on that in Congress.
They're working on that in Congress.
It's one of the dopiest things of all time.
If you don't know if you've heard this podcast,
you probably heard me complain about it,
but if you don't know it,
you should Google it.
Google why hemp became illegal.
It'll drive you crazy.
It's not even like psychoactive.
The stuff that they make clothes out of the stuff.
No good.
It's all because the other people who are,
have those businesses locked down,
whether it's the paper industry,
whether it's the pharmaceutical industry,
whether they're like,
this is no way you're even getting that up cousin of that fucking thing.
Legal.
Alright,
think about it.
So literally the cousin of weed that doesn't get you high is illegal too.
And is there a better marketing tagline then?
It's not even legal in this country.
That's the bad marketing,
but it's even stupider because it is legal in this country.
We just can't grow it here where you can buy it,
we can buy it from Canada and then we can only,
because it's so,
it's,
it's hard to get the highest quality stuff.
We can only buy 50 pounds of this shit a day and that's all you can get because
they just,
everybody's trying to buy it because we can't grow it in America.
Like farmers are fucked because first of all,
we have,
excuse me,
way easier to grow like a weed corn to get infested by bugs.
Like good luck getting weed infested.
Yeah,
we will fight off every bug.
What do you ever heard about anybody losing a crop to bugs?
I may have experienced some worms.
Really outdoor.
It's like a big foot story.
I'll and worms.
It was.
It required
tweezers and a lot of fucking time,
man.
What do you tell how many days work Mandela?
Jenny,
you would dump more than I would.
I believe so.
I'll go with you.
Well,
I was talking shit.
Let me know later.
I was talking a little shit.
I will let you know later.
But you're still plugging things.
You're like fucking marathon right now.
It's over.
It's over the marathon zone.
You were so entertaining.
Brogan are such a brand.
So marketable.
I have to pay for bandwidth in this table.
So table,
I got the nice table.
Reclaimed.
Yes it is.
It's old Russian lumber,
something like that.
I made that up.
Now it's like a,
it's a farm like a hundred year old oak.
They saw those.
I don't really go to the factory,
so it's fucking really a hundred years old.
Brown,
have you been through the Midwest?
Like those parts of Detroit that were gone?
West is emptied out some crises and then we think,
shit that's a hundred years old is old.
I was just in England hanging out at my buddy's house was built in 1450 hang
drinking in a pub buddy Earl or says,
you know Chris Harris,
right?
You don't have,
let's let,
let me just end this.
Press the press.
No,
no.
We have to start to music.
We have two different parts of the podcast.
Like we're serious picks it up.
I mean it's a good way to do this thing.
Doesn't kick in,
does it means we don't,
it's not like officially started.
I mean we have,
we've abandoned that tactic at least a half a dozen times in the past.
I tried to have some sort of semblance of a control that too.
Yeah,
for sure.
But it's more like,
like pageantry and I like to start at so stupid.
I know.
It's stupid.
I do it.
Anyway.
Showbiz tradition.
What separates the pros from that?
This arm,
this arm right here is all it takes.
Yeah.
You gotta have one of them.
You want the part?
Yeah,
I've had like those table mounted ones.
We have the table mountain one.
I like to compare.
Hold on to take this shit.
The whole on the tables to move.
I feel like you're a goddamn professional.
Yeah.
Once you start drilling hundred year old wood,
there's not the clamp on the side,
like the college lamp.
The architect lamp with a c clamp.
No,
there's a hole in this table.
There's a hole in this table isn't perfect.
Yes.
We had it set up.
That's Todd Mesereau who is the executive producer of my new TV show,
which is a Joe Rogan questions,
everything and this is Matt Farah.
Matt Farah is,
if you are a fan of cars and you fan of cool car videos,
you might already know him.
You might know him from drive or the smoking,
tire.com the crepe plug.
Cho.
I enjoy you.
I enjoy your,
your videos,
man.
I really do.
I think they're really fun.
The first one I saw was you have a,
you were in a Ferrari four,
five,
eight in like New Jersey or had the Russian guy in the trunk.
I don't remember a Russian guy in the trunk of a Ferrari to demonstrate how big
a trunk it had.
It was smuggling immigrants.
What I liked about it better,
God's like,
you were just like a fun dude who was checking out bad ass cars.
It was being yourself.
Whereas like next up,
the new Ford Fairlane amazing dual clutch transmission.
Like there's like this fake goofy voice that's so many dudes had and those car
video seriousness,
they ruined cars like watching car videos to me because I'd be like,
you stuffy motherfucker.
Let's grab this bull by the horns and see if we hang on and you'd be better off
just letting you look at the car.
But I think all credit due to the original top gear,
right?
They're the guys who like started cracked it open.
Right?
Pretty much like for a sense of humor and Tommy Clarkson.
Now Todd Todd worked on the reboot of the u s top gear.
This is where Matt and I and we met with Adam Carolla as as the Jeremy Clarkson
character and Tanner Foust and he hadn't,
they call Todd got up,
found me and called me to audition for that,
the u s top gear and I didn't make it.
You made it to the final round.
You would have been good.
I would've been.
I might've been good as history has proven because look at you.
You know you had a speed show from his top gear.
It tends to be the little scripted.
I don't do scripted.
I think that's why you were spine.
Just talk.
You guys are kind of alike that way.
Yeah.
I'm well,
Adam Ferrara is a good buddy of mine from back in New York.
Great,
isn't he?
He's a sweetie pie.
I love that dude.
He's a great,
great guy.
I've been friends with him forever.
We were pool playing buddies.
I wish they let him talk a little more on that show.
Well,
yeah.
You know what it's like.
They're,
the things are,
they're funny when they like,
like he had a really funny one with a corvette Zr one who's like defending
America and the stupidity of a corvette Zr one.
And Tanner had this beautiful Ferrari and right.
You know,
and it was a,
it was funny like Ferrara that was like,
you could tell like Ferrara had a saying that his queens,
you know,
Italian is unlocked.
It's unlocked.
Got that market fully covered.
But it's like the,
I can't help but when I see them standing up just like Jeremy Clarkson and
Richard Harris is,
that was his name.
Hammond.
Richard hammered and the other dude,
what's the other dude?
Slow James May,
James May.
Those guys,
when I see them standing up,
that's like,
they would have been doing that forever.
That's their shit.
And when you repeat age over the stance,
but when you see like Adam and Tanner doing this,
it's like you guys are just like,
you're doing what they did,
right?
Like you don't have to do what they did.
Yeah.
You don't even have to call it top gear.
Just do a good car.
Shit.
I kind of sell the brand,
you know,
that's how the television industry,
I know it's a hit show,
it'll be a hit show here.
They've managed to take three really entertaining guys who know a lot about cars
early come kind of boring.
That's going to help me drive.
The best part about drive is it lets people be themselves.
So you have distinct characters who are generally,
they're the same if you meet them in real life.
And I knew it when Todd sent me the final cut of the u s top gear that had Adam
in it.
Adam Carolla,
we call that my last episode.
I watched it and I go,
holy fuck,
this is a very good top gear cover band.
So
you know,
I couldn't watch it cause it was too strange.
But you know what that,
that Tanner Foust guy's really good.
He's a really good driver.
First of all,
he can drive on the mother fucker.
He's intense and like he like,
he's very engaging.
When he communicates.
He did a thing on the corvette,
z o six and it was racing against a motorcycle and it was fucking Donald.
That was awesome,
dude.
They had these fucking crazy cargo crate set up and they essentially put this
like obstacle course together and he's racing a motorcycle around this obstacle
course and he's going sideways around corners and catching it perfect.
And just going clean into these lines with this fucking corvette.
Z O six he did a,
he did a,
he's got a real video after like mastering block.
Yeah.
I mean after Jim [inaudible] came out,
Tanner wanted some of that action.
Yeah,
so he did,
he did the Mulholland drive street drift video.
I remember that video yet.
It's PSI on formula drift car and went up the snake on Mulholland,
but he made a very big deal out of doing it in one take and not having any tire
marks be there to show multiple takes.
So I was there when he did it and he drifted the entire snake once and it was
like,
whoa.
Oh my God,
this,
he's nuts.
But he's,
people got to know what that means.
What is drifting.
The snake means when,
when someone has a very powerful sports car,
you can manipulate the way the car steers with the throttle,
but it requires a very delicate touch.
You have to really know what you're doing and to go up a crazy path.
The windy road like road called the snake man.
I mean just imagine,
you know the most fan film that was Ryan there from Ryan was there filming that
and I filmed the behind the scenes.
They spent a lot of money and we spend no money and we got half the view.
So one of my favorite videos of all time,
I don't know if you've ever seen it,
is a gt three on a mountain road.
Jamie puts,
see if he could pull that up.
Gt three and a mountain road.
Jeff's wart video,
I don't know who this bad motherfucker has a code.
This guy crushing a gt three on a mountain road in this is going sideways around
corners.
There's like ledges,
I mean Pike's peak or I don't know where it was.
Just says gt three and a mountain road.
I think if I feel like it was somewhere in Europe,
but homeboy was fa lie gang up this mountain road and you're just shitting your
pants sweating while you're watching and he's going sideways blog and you're
with him while he's doing this cat.
This mother fucker can drive.
Dude,
this guy's going for it.
I don't know where he's going,
Chris Harris.
I don't think it is.
I don't think this one's Chris Harris with Chris Harris says many of these.
It looks like you're a baby.
I get Invidi in cars with a lot of people.
You know he really fucking scares me.
He cause he really,
he was going what I would do.
That's nice.
Look at this motherfucker.
Woo feet from a brick wall.
He's sliding sideways hitting the gas on the time.
That looked a lot like Chris Harris for a second.
Hey,
it might be him.
It could be,
that's something he would do.
He was going what I would consider a fucking race pace on a Welsh back road.
You know,
and I'm hitting I,
it's right hand drive cause we're in Wales so I'm in the where the driver would
normally be and hearing the reads against the mirror,
you know,
as we're going a hundred down a one lane road blind corners,
crazy.
Have you seen the video of him testing out the new gt three?
Yes.
Yeah.
Pull that up.
Gene.
Chris Harris,
nine nine one one gt three is what I did.
Come on.
Your show is talking about Chris Harris.
He was,
you're talking about life,
talking about life.
We're going to love this,
but did you got my attention all night?
Thanks.
Thank you.
Thank you man.
Thanks man.
Those videos like guys like Chris Harris,
guys like you.
They're like,
there's those videos didn't exist just a few years ago and they've made like,
what's really fun is that like,
I would like to sit down with a Chris Harris.
I like to hang out with that dude.
I like to hang out with you.
You know,
I'd like to show people that like,
it's not like a Steffi,
a stuffy like stiff presenter,
right?
It's like they're,
they're being honest about what these fucking things like a child like
appreciation for cars,
you know what I mean?
It's almost like a toy.
[inaudible] Chris is like a child.
He's like half of my fucking size and Tanner looks like a child even though he's
40 Tanner Foust,
youngest looking 40 years.
You been in a car with him with Tanner?
Yes it is.
You know,
you're sitting in the seat and you and he,
the funny thing is I love when people try and scare the shit out of you.
Like I was in a power boat doing 90 I was in the back seat and they're looking
back like they're waiting for me to puke and because they're having fun,
they're trying to fuck with me.
I'm not really a fan of that tank.
But Tanner,
I never had a moment of fear cause Tanner just has this touch and you just,
you know,
you're sitting in the car.
He was going to be fine.
Can I tell you my favorite Tanner Foust story?
It's not very long,
but I promise you'll like it.
I actually,
I got him in a lot of trouble,
but I figure I can only get him in trouble for this story once so I can tell it
again.
So there was a thing called the octane academy in Detroit where they had a bunch
of media come out and do four different driving disciplines with different pros.
Okay.
So the stunt driving section was with Tanner on a wet skid pad in a Ford focus
the night before.
It was von Gittens birthday and volumes,
a formula drift driver.
And he was there too.
And Ken Block was there and a and Brian Deegan,
another four drivers there.
So,
and I know those guys.
I was like,
I'm getting you fucked up tonight.
And I got Tanner like blackout drunk whiskey that night and the next day he was
so hung over and Todd could tell you Tanner's a terrible passenger.
Amazing driver,
terrible passenger.
And so he was riding shotgun with people who for the most part,
we're not very good drivers learning how to do three on
a wet skit.
Bad like handbrake turns the after a full night of drinking whiskey with me,
he was the most miserable hate him.
Oh Man.
And then I published a picture of him drunk and give me the finger on Facebook
and he had an a la Trobe.
Sorry Tanner.
Publicly.
It never ends.
The Fun with cars.
No.
Yeah,
there's a video of Tanner,
uh,
test driving a Porsche gt two rs,
that crazy fucking new one.
Nine line seven,
the only new Porsche that really wants you dead.
It's so scary,
that thing.
And he's going sideways around corners with it in downtown La.
They cordoned off parts of downtown La to fail.
I don't know.
You know how the Oh yeah.
The streets are saying,
yeah,
yeah.
So I saw that'd be fun to do the terrifying,
I don't know how to fucking drive like that.
If I found myself going sideways,
that'd be shitting my pants.
I was at willow springs one day and Jason Statham shows up in a gt two and I
love Jason Statham.
I was fucking site and he was the nicest guy in the world.
And he smelled exactly like you'd expect Jason State them to smell.
You smell them close enough.
Yeah.
And like I could just like,
man,
like a man smells like he smells like a moan or like a real smell.
Smells like he could be ravaging of vagina within five seconds of going on
though.
And,
and I didn't get that impression.
I met him,
seemed like a really nice guy.
I didn't think he was going to get me pregnant.
So he has a g and he's never been on a race track before and you know,
200 miles on it.
Oh No.
So he's like,
all right,
anybody got a helmet?
And I was like,
Oh,
here you go man.
I gave him my helmet.
Oh No.
And he went out on the track,
on the streets of willow and turned one.
Exited the track.
It's such an extraordinary rate.
Oh my first term.
Oh my God.
He didn't make it one corner.
She's a poor guy.
Oh man,
I don't if you've never driven something like that before.
Yeah,
you don't want to hit it.
Right.
Those are really tricky to gt two is a turbo for folks who are not up on the
Porsche terminology and with turbo,
even though they've kinda got it licked with the,
there's something called turbo lag.
They've Kinda got it licked but not totally,
there's still like a little flexibility to like the way the power gets delivered
and the tires break away.
So easy.
Yeah.
So you're dealing with this weird out a touch feeling for how much power gets to
the engine,
wears what people really like is a naturally aspirated engine because you,
you,
you sell it,
you feel it,
you feel like there's no instant throttle.
The feedback is appropriate,
but that gt two is yet please.
It's super stupid powerful.
And it's a turbo and it's two wheel drive.
It's not four wheel drive,
so it's just a recipe for chaos.
100% disasters.
Porsche horsepower is a little bit different from other horsepower.
Like,
for instance,
the,
uh,
us a 520 horsepower Porsche turbo is way faster than a 660 horsepower Shelby
Mustang.
Different thing.
Yeah.
And like,
like for instance I ran and where the engine,
yeah.
And I ran a corvette zr one at the Mojave mile and I ran a one one 76 and the
standing miles was zero to 176 miles an hour at one mile.
A Porsche turbo out of the box does one 84,
which is a big deal.
It's a big difference for a car that has 120 less horsepower.
So these things are stupid,
stupid,
fast.
And if you don't know what you're doing,
you're probably going to die.
Yeah.
You have a stupid fast forward.
What's up with your car?
Your three Rs?
The shark works car.
Yeah,
it's a stroker motor,
right?
502 horsepower.
They take a 3.6 and take it to 3.9 and it's,
it's probably is all for people don't know cars.
This is all their fucking poke in their ears with pencils.
Right now
your crowd is ruling.
I'm,
I'm absolutely fascinated by performance cars,
like real performance cars,
cars that handle,
you know like I've had muscle cars before and I love them for a different
reason.
You just said that I kind of first became a fan of you a with the Carlos Mencia
thing,
which,
which was fucking great.
And then when I saw the sick fish on fucking ride some shit as it rides,
it was a car.
I mean it probably did it drive good.
It looks good.
It I'm,
it drove like a rhinoceros on roller skates.
Nobody wants I guess the same muscle cars drive like the ass,
but they do.
Some of them don't.
I'm like,
you know they,
I know you know about XV motor sports.
I know.
What do you think about that?
Have you driven it?
I've driven XV card.
It's very nice.
They did their very expensive,
it's like a singer Porsche.
It's crazy expensive.
Exactly.
But they're dope.
Yeah.
I know.
Someone who could build you something just as nice for less money.
That kind of style is very appealing to me.
But the old style,
the old style of like ancient suspension,
ancient breaks.
You can go fuck yourself.
I have no needs it.
It's like dressing up as a civil war.
Reenactor yeah,
like I don't want to wear wool underwear way better shit.
There was some dudes want that old steamer and wheel brakes.
They want everything.
They want to be in a time machine.
Essentially.
They go to the fucking [inaudible] fucking me and you want to go find that
boombox and throw it off a bridge.
Who wants to be old?
I don't want to be old to new shit.
The shit that works.
What is it about folks that really love those numbers?
Matching old cars though to the point where they collect the most money.
The most money cars are the low mileage old cars.
That's a history thing and it's a hot wheel.
It's like a really expensive hot way.
I think they're stupid.
I have an uncle that bought a 65 corvette like I think he bought it essentially
as an investment.
That's
a good ass numbers matching.
He'll,
he'll make money.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's a convertible.
He's like,
I think he's driven that thing four times mean his whole life and seeing the
prices of of recent some days off recently.
It's crazy.
Yeah,
I have some of them like it's for certain like numbers matching cards that are
difficult to find.
Like you see insane was $7 car for 26 Hemi built on a Thursday with rally wheels
and green stripes.
On the other hand,
I didn't want to tell Todd before the podcasts,
cause I've,
I've bought two cars in the last three weeks.
Fine.
So one of them was a Chevy volt and it's my commuter car.
I can debate the merits of electric car and news,
how Douchey I am in fucking 10 minutes.
But the other one is more pertinent conversation because I bought a 1982 barn,
find numbers matching Delorean with 2000 miles.
I saw you're no longer a store.
It's a Delorean for folks who don't know what that is.
That's the back to the future car.
If you a stainless steel.
And if you were around when I was a kid,
that's um,
when there was that famous case,
what happened?
John Delorean,
who created the company,
was trying to raise money to keep the company going and he'd be selling some
coke or something.
May or may not have a low blow blankets.
It's unknown.
I mean,
he got off right Denise?
Yes,
he got off but off of the company was done.
So he got off but the company was killed.
So there was a company that swept in after they went bankrupt and bought all of
their assets.
Okay.
And a guy named Steven Wynn bought the assets from this company and opened up
shop in Texas.
So he has the entire Delorean factories worth of parts and it's the official
restoration place.
And they do a couple hundred restorations a year.
They have enough parts.
People love these cards.
They have enough bars,
thousand brand new complete cars.
That's how many parts they have for Deloreans.
That's incredible.
So I can,
it would be the same specs as they were back in the 1991 for 56 grand.
They'll build you a brand new 1981 delorean right now and,
and so I bought it.
I got this car,
blue cal blue plates,
original blue plates on it.
2000 miles.
That's big Deckard Dorks,
right?
The original blue plate.
That's a big data nerd thing.
But they're in such,
they're brand new.
The cars were going to fucking storage unit for 30 years.
Who found it?
They did.
They knew I was looking and they called me.
And so,
and they're doing a restoration but with new brakes,
new HVAC,
new electronics,
same engine,
but they're hot.
Rodding it up a bit.
The stage to upgrade how many horsepower?
215 horsepower with the car only weighs 2,700 pounds.
So it's roughly an eighties nine 11 Howard or wait,
yeah,
so that's my nerd mobile that I just bought and I'm site.
Why they have the doors that you know going towards,
I didn't know they were that light.
Yeah,
it's you guys in the stainless steel body over a fiberglass monocoque.
That's why it's why they're very light.
Also why they don't go around corners very well.
It's not much of a driving experience evidently.
Does it just make you smile when you say,
because dude,
I,
you know,
I use unique.
Are you,
do you think that everything needs to go zillion miles an hour?
Are you one of those people?
No.
No,
not at all.
Not at all.
I used to think that now I sit and fucking traffic all day.
So I bought a volt that's called wisdom,
that wisdom and I bought a Delorean automotive driving slow.
Well,
there's no,
listen,
I,
there's no need to drive fast,
you know,
I already got to ask really?
You can scars every now and then drive fast every now and again.
But just driving cars is fun.
Yeah.
Good.
Do you remember when you were a kid?
The first time you get to drive a car you're like,
Holy Shit,
I'm driving.
You know,
like,
I can't believe I'm in the street.
Like we should still enjoy it.
Well,
the Delorean was the car when I was four.
My Dad brought me a car magazine and I was flipping and I saw the Delorean with
the gullwing doors and it looked like from the future and it was like,
that was the car that made me think that cars could be something more than like
what my mom took me to fucking preschool in.
Right.
You know,
it's not a to,
that's it.
There's no wrong,
there's no reason for buying a Delorean besides,
it will appreciate in value over time.
And it's what I want.
That's it.
And it's,
it to me represents what they thought the future was gonna look like.
That's really strange how it missed.
You know,
like whenever the people like look to like design something that's going to be
like this is the future car had flying cars but no cell phones and what the
fuck.
After a while though,
they still look clunky.
It's weird.
Like they don't ever totally get it.
Like have you seen the Time magazine?
Do you know the demand minster fuller three wheeled car and it's
like a motorcycle?
No,
the rear wheel steers.
Wow.
Like a Cessna without wings.
Yeah,
that's exactly.
It looks like a spaceship fuselage with three two wheels in the front and one
wheel in the back and it had all these safety features.
Like what?
He goes,
I had trucks that seat belts in the 20s look at a whipping donuts.
Right?
Oh my God.
That's ridiculous.
That doesn't look like your dream of the future.
When they made that,
that looks like a giant Usb port,
like one of those little cute little beak USB sticks that you stick in your lap.
That's amazing.
Yeah.
Cause you had all the cables going.
This is the guy he designed the geodesic dome.
He was one of those genius engineers.
There's one in the valley that I've seen.
There's one in Malibu to his up on,
up off a ladder.
Go Canyon structure,
isn't it?
It's a weird structure,
but it exists in nature.
They found something called Buckminster Fuller Marine and it's that weird shape.
You know all the different sides.
Naturally they
named,
they named these things they found in nature after Buckminster fuller because it
has the same shape as the geodesic dome.
Wow.
That's crazy.
So he came up with it independently.
Yeah.
That's amazing.
And then they went and found it and Bucky balls,
they're called now
Splore superconducting materials and all this other high and super geeky tech
stuff that I only half understand.
I just know the words.
Yeah,
those geodesic domes.
And when they,
when they start finding,
um,
one of the weirdest things that I ever saw about,
uh,
plants and the shapes of plants was a,
the FIBONACCI sequence when they started showing it,
and I was watching this swear on sunflower seeds.
They're showing how sunflowers the golden,
yeah.
The Acropolis in Athens.
Yeah.
Well for folks who don't,
I'm not even remotely skilled enough in mathematics to really explain the
FIBONACCI seen these,
I think it's essentially zero and then one and one and two and two and one is
few.
Added the numbers up.
Yeah.
You add hope.
That's right.
I'm pretty sure that's what it is right there.
That's it.
Yeah.
So it's,
yeah.
Two,
three,
five.
You know what else uses that same golden mean Aston Martin,
every single one of their cars.
If you measure that's interesting.
Heights and lengths and widths of certain things all over the car.
I used that same even today,
like in the size of the grill versus how high the nose of the car is off the
ground.
The window versus the whole.
Makes Sense.
We're statically beautiful car.
That is that those Aston Martin cars are stunning of love.
That they're works of art.
They're like modern works of art.
The drive.
Yeah.
They really are.
I have an older one.
It's awesome.
Dan Cook had one though.
He said it.
He had flood,
he was on the podcast and he was talking about,
he said he thought he was fucking James Bond.
He taught,
he's like Cube Cube shoe.
Like pretending like shooting people out of his car was drunk and he goes,
it was such a piece of shit.
He was like laughing about how it broke down.
Oh,
I haven't had an issue with in a year.
You know,
it's like wine.
There's good years and bad years of British cards.
What happened those days?
Old stuff,
man.
You've got to roll the dice.
Sometimes it's be spoke.
Um,
I'm the only problem that fucking exactly.
First I had a nine,
nine six turbo Porsche nine nine six turbo that broke down five times
catastrophic failure.
We'll shrink years and Jen had to be replaced.
Um,
the clutch linkage disappeared twice where I was backing out of a parking spot.
Just claim claimed to claim completely loose,
no gears,
couldn't do shit.
Had to get towed twice.
Once the fuel pump blue and once the gas gauge died,
nine,
six is,
or like the fucking bottomless pit Porsches Friday afternoon,
six career right now for like eight grand.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
It's amazing because they're very good car.
It's a very good car.
But like the nine,
nine threes,
which weren't as technologically advanced or like more expensive and air.
Cool.
The Porsche people are all about that air cooled.
Yeah.
They love that.
Why is that?
Why is it because their traditionalist.
What about fucking dude?
I don't know who's worse portion Mueller,
Ferrari people that I think they're equally horrible now.
Ferrari there we'll have more money.
There's second BMW people who think they're rich,
but aren't you driving?
If you're driving a Ferrari,
you're really Paulin.
If you driving a Porsche,
you probably can't afford it.
I always remember that line from entourage.
Kevin does a goal.
You just lease it.
That's so all the assholes in this town drive nine 11 it's true,
I'm sure,
but at Lino leasing it,
if it works,
great deal.
You get to drive a sweet fucking car that you could never really afford and just
give that shit back after you've beat the shit out of.
I'm going to auto cross that Shin.
Why not off road with a volt?
We're about to do 500 miles off road,
bro.
Tomorrow.
Isn't this a,
this is a really cool time if you enjoy cars because even the,
there's a bunch of American cars that have caught up like this and these new
Camaro's the and the ss that's coming out or not the not the ss to the Chevy ss.
What is the,
no,
there's,
there's a new Camaro that's coming out.
It has a corvette engine.
Oh,
there's a,
the z 28 28 28 is a race version where it only has one speaker.
So that you can hear the seatbelt.
Ding,
Ding.
That's it.
No radio,
no bullshit.
And it's like 30003000200 pounds and fucking 500 horsepower.
Naturally aspirated and magnetic fiber brakes,
carbon fiber brakes standard.
It's going to be just a radical [inaudible] grand and I handle like a mother
fucker.
That magnetic,
they're valued.
This car is the best thing they make is the mid,
the magnetic ride suspension.
Yeah.
I had a Zl one and I couldn't believe how far between.
No,
no,
no.
It's a much more crude.
It's a different sort of,
but it's also a third of the price that it is a wicked fucking car,
man.
That's a real legit sports cars.
Eight views.
What's that?
You got to pull the number eight fuse.
If you buy one,
that's the electronic exhausts.
Baffles.
If you pull it,
they stay wired open all the time.
They have sport thing.
Yeah,
we can press you always drive by noise regulations.
They suck.
That's so silly.
That's why I have to have them.
My card it.
Fuck that lack of your own car.
You are.
You are radical.
I'm fucking low cats.
You're contributing to global warming.
What about the seals,
man?
Are you saying that 800 miles a year I was driving that car contributes to
Goldman.
When I bought,
I bought a volt fucker.
When I bought the Karma thing,
I like,
Hey,
think Joey,
he can wait a thing.
Buys carbon offsets,
right?
I do.
I buy,
I bought the volt and then the raptor a corvette and it's a good mood.
Yeah,
that's a good mood.
That's why my wife drives a Prius.
Well,
you know,
in five years they'll have some new technology that siphons carbon out of the
air and powers our homes and they'll get mad at you if you don't drive your car
enough because it is not a car.
That energy at the empire weren't flourish.
You know,
there'll be,
they'll figure out a way to suck pollution out of the atmosphere and actually
turn it up and use it as fuel.
And when they did,
when and if they did,
they're going to fucking do it.
Someone's got to do it.
It's out there.
There's gotta be a really smart idea because just coming and going,
there'll be mad at us for not driving enough.
They'll tell us if you start driving old cars,
old shitty cars that will bring back letters.
All the fucking cars in the in the world don't offset like,
like ships and planes
or ships,
diesel emissions,
anything running back and forth constant.
We should go back to sail boats.
Little fuel out,
sailboats,
sailboats.
Well,
you know,
we should go back and get,
just have assholes row.
Right?
How's that?
We haven't grown making them grow your down voted as a youtube comment or you
have to row.
That's perfect.
Youtube.
Commentors is there ever been a vial or group of human beings and lowest legacy
stairs?
Lowest form of life on the planet?
Well,
it's not just what it is is the Internet commentators in general.
It's like,
and it's not.
It's totally in general and a lot of your coolest fuck,
no doubt about it.
But there's a lot of people,
I get a lot of cool.
I may interact with a lot of cool people online.
No doubt about it.
I like the online cannot.
So there's so many people out there that just try to,
will you let go to their Twitter page and they're just continent up with every
word.
Talking Carlin about this.
Me and Dan Carlin,
we were having a conversation.
It's true though because you have nothing else to do or they like it.
There's people that like getting you angry.
But if you saw them on the street,
probably they'd be the most timid.
Well,
he responded well.
He was never do anything.
You know,
unfortunately they beat me a lot,
which sucks.
They fucking wind,
which really pissed.
I,
I've,
I've like resigned from Youtube commenting like three times,
like as many times.
Like you can't help yourself or you like the Alec Baldwin,
you're a fun guy and anyone who's a fun guy can easily be criticized.
It's easy to criticize anybody who drives fast cars.
It's easy to criticize anybody who compares cars to tits and ass,
but it's also fun.
That is a way to make a living,
isn't it?
Nothing wrong with it.
It's fun.
But it's the honest living,
the idea of everybody getting a say.
And,
and,
and what is good and what is bad is in new thing and some brand new people
shouldn't get a duck.
A fucking say,
you know,
variation Ernie Kumi of you and I appreciate that.
It's my life's goal.
No offense to do the OB Anthony show shallow goal,
but it's my entire life's goal to do.
Tell you what,
man,
if you want to fly out there,
I'm going to do it next time the UFC is in New Jersey real estate.
You want to bring me all weekend?
I go mandate and Opie and Anthony,
you're coming with me,
man.
I'll introduce you to those guys.
They would love you.
You would love them too.
That's the back to his car though.
That's part of the Aston Martin.
Anthony has a crazy Shelby Mustang and he was like 800 horsepower.
Fucking wrecked it.
Dude.
I don't know why I fucking die or
no comment.
Your honor is involved in that scenario.
So it was just simply a Roomba.
I said,
do well on that sheet.
Yeah.
Yeah,
he'd be perfect once they made fun of me.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I called them once.
They made fun of me and they,
and,
and rightfully so.
I called him with a fucking Douchey.
Has Shit ever.
How old were you?
22 Oh,
okay.
Each badge of honor.
You make fun of each other.
I to be an Anthony are fine man.
The first show that I ever did where I kind of learned that you didn't have to
really structure anything.
You could just go have fun free for those guys.
They have comics on,
they would have like Patrice,
Louis,
c,
k me,
you know,
whoever that anybody would come in and has to.
Jim Norton of course.
And everybody would just start talking and it was just a conversation amongst
friends and if you tried to get like sticky with them,
you tried to like throw in your bids the fuck she call you on it,
they shut you down.
It's just like friends fucking talking.
Danny rose,
Howard Stern for sure.
For sure.
We owe him the greatest dead.
He's the the original pioneer of like that kind of free wild radio in my
opinion.
But then opie and Anthony brought it to a different place because they,
they had more of a hang,
their show was like a 40 hour plus five hour,
whatever it was hanged.
Yeah.
It was a big shuffle in and out now.
And I would stay on while other guests came on to Ed Asner came on once and they
go,
come on,
it's hang on,
show had asthma come in and you know,
not to talk when Ed's talking and you know,
let them discuss things that he wants to discuss it.
But it's like,
it's a hang,
it's like you get a chance to sit down with fucking,
you're chilling with a bunch of people's mark when he's Mary Tyler Moore's boss.
Oh.
Um,
he had a show.
I remember we went from William Mary,
Tom Morris boss to like be in like serious,
had like a serious show.
We was the same characters and everybody was like,
what the fuck is this?
Cause he was Mary Tyler Moore's boss.
Right.
Come back Kotter.
I know who you mean,
but I can't think of his name.
I'm not old enough.
I don't think so.
I remember Ed Asner,
he was still around.
It's still hilarious and as an her Mary Tyler Moore's boss.
Yeah,
he was and did the Marion charm or show.
It was a new branching was about a newsroom and I am going to be this way
because if we can think of,
it was weird because it was like all the sudden it was a series show.
We're very comedy show.
Exactly.
It was a really serious show.
Was kind of like the Washington Post or the New York Times.
It was all drama.
It was before Aaron Sorkin.
Yeah.
It was better than the newsroom.
It was really weird though.
It was like all of the sudden this guy knows from being on this hilarious
comedy,
the Korean same characters like,
well,
I've got dark.
The curmudgeon leading news guy at one point I grant grant.
That's it.
At one point in time he was playing for his show.
Looks depressing as fuck.
Yo.
This show really does show is depressing and it was not just depressing.
It was weird.
Yeah.
Looks the pressing.
Doesn't that look depressing?
Yeah.
I Miss Ted.
I Miss Ted Baxter.
The anchorman.
It was weird because it was the shift from the original show,
which was completely comedy based to all of a sudden this guy's depressed as
fuck.
Right.
Every episode is like someone's trying to kill somebody.
And by the way,
is that Livia Soprano?
That's Tony Soprano's mother,
isn't it?
That's Livia.
Oh my God.
Look at that for a spot that she looks like she's six foot tall.
That fucking picture.
You're dead correct.
Look at you.
You got a thing for her.
That shit I can pull see list actors out my ace.
I love people to know pop culture.
It's like,
I hate to go into a meeting and a reference something and then I feel like that
old guy talking about shit,
nobody knows anything about bad cops.
Fucking Ed Asner.
Yeah,
exactly.
Bad Cop shows or one of my favorite things of all time.
So much so that there was a show called Delavan tour.
I remember the name.
And then my manager also manages Kevin James,
who's a the king and queen.
Right.
And they were on the same network as Danny Aiello when he had this show called
Della Ventura.
And they had them get me the tapes because you couldn't find them.
I have the original master.
Yes,
VHS tapes.
Great show.
It's horrible and awesome at the same time.
I cherish these tapes.
I have people over for Delavan tour watching parties.
You bumped them over to a digital.
I have to do that.
I'm sorry.
It's so bad.
It's so awesome.
You only get so many runs on the tape,
so you gotta.
You gotta transfer that show.
I haven't watched them in years.
I can.
I have them like in a sacred spot,
have candles around them and make sure I keep them safe.
I thought it'd be a really good idea to buy first season,
macgyver DVD box set.
I was like,
fuck it.
Let me tell you about my grammar.
Macgyver is infinitely better than Dylan.
I mean,
it's not measurable.
Delavan Tory is one of the worst shows the world has ever known,
but that's where we are.
An old man beats up every young punk that crosses his eye.
He's the best at everything he does.
The Grand Torino fucking you will drown in Danny Aiello is ego.
You will a juror round.
You will never make it out alive.
Good and do the right thing so well,
he's an amazing listener.
No bullshit.
I don't know who made the script.
I don't know what the fuck happened.
My show.
I'm talking my shit.
I'm talking shit.
Maybe Danny thought it was a subtle comedy,
but he's an amazing actor.
There's no,
you can't take that away from them.
The Guy,
he's an incredible actor and so of course he has a bit of an ego.
He's,
he's,
he's fucking bad ass.
He's a bad ass actor.
But still,
that show was so bad.
It hurt your feelings.
It was so bad you would watch me go,
Holy Shit.
Like he plays pool.
He plays pool with this guy,
this young punk,
and he fucking shoots in every ball and the guy goes,
you're the best I've ever seen.
Mr. What's your secret?
He goes,
my secret,
don't miss
the best,
worst show ever.
You feel this fall in a fetal position and and break your own fingers because
you squeezing them so tightly,
so embarrassed for him.
Let me tell you what the first,
how many episodes?
I don't know.
This had two seasons I think.
I think it went to see,
they might've been just one season.
I'm not sure.
I have a nice box of 'em the first season of macgyver it to watch it.
Three quarters voiceover.
Oh,
random jungle shots.
Like helicopter over the jug with like,
and then I broke him out of prison.
It's like him.
No way are you got shots and then it's like next voiceover.
It's the most bullshit thing.
It really,
that bad.
They could have shot the entire season and about four days they probably did.
It was cheap.
Fucking Richard Dean Anderson in the booth.
He was not in target.
That's hilarious.
Those old fucking old crime shows cop and crime shows are so awesome.
Well,
iron side,
you remember a guy in a wheelchair,
they're remaking iron side for NBC.
Oh my God.
They are with Blair Underwood as the,
uh,
as the guy who's Blair Underwood.
But I know that I'm supposed to African American actor.
He was in a,
an NBC show last season where he's the president and there's this other
dimension or people from another word though.
They're aliens.
Actually it was,
uh,
it was actually a really cool show you've been on.
NBC made it sound terrible.
It made one season.
I'm still thinking about Delavan Torah.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
focus.
Would you rather you want to call it?
Call it early and go elements.
It's just,
it was such a great show.
It's such a great show for all the wrong reasons.
Yeah,
that sounds awesome.
It's like the $6 million man.
Do you do a like a back to back?
No.
$6 million man.
Was it from a different era?
You know,
it wasn't as,
it wasn't as groovy.
Okay.
You,
you gotta jump to you.
How fucking old are you?
45 see you got,
do you have 14 years old?
You homie?
Yeah.
And we are trying to tell a vendor references.
Yes.
What you young I liked,
I liked being bald.
It makes me feel like I'm the old motherfucker.
You older than Todd?
He's the oldest.
He knows.
No,
no.
Say it would be a very weird,
I'm much older,
like Tanner Foust,
almost as old as Joe and looks like a child.
Yeah,
he's very baby faced.
He's,
you know,
he does is,
that's what happened.
We just went,
well,
maybe driving that fast.
She just numb your nerves.
Heim is different.
I know.
Bob Bonderant,
you know Bob Onder on his blog or on school of high performance driving penis on
a great track and Phoenix,
the guy was like,
he drove around with m four gts back fucking the 24 hours of Lamont in a Shelby
Cobra.
That's how bad ass he is.
He,
he won the gnarliest race in the world,
in the scariest car ever made.
That's all you need to know.
But he took on every driver on the plan.
Like Americans in those days weren't winning on all these international
circuits.
The Europeans kicked our ass all the time.
And then Enzo Ferrari was like shitting in our mouths on a weekly basis.
Exactly.
Phil Hill came along and Bob Bonderant [inaudible],
Carol Shelby,
it was went on just smash.
Kind of bizarre because in those days in America,
like road racing wasn't the same thing like it was way below football,
baseball,
basketball.
So I used bond odds track in Arizona sometimes and he's 78 years old and he's
there every day and he has a much younger,
very lovely wife.
She's pat is Mark Patterson,
great brains behind the whole thing.
He didn't have his name on the car and she's a marketing agency and so she,
you know,
he's 88 and I go out with heart and bless his heart.
How old is she in her fifties and I'll go,
I'll go out with him in a corvette.
Zr 178 years old will,
oh I do eight labs every day to keep my reflexes sharp.
And you go,
as you're getting in the car and you go and you go,
oh my God,
this is,
this is the end.
It's going to say Paul Baran and one identify unidentified other person died
today and then he goes like hug sitting sideways.
He can drive.
Like,
imagine you go with your grandfather and having him drift the whole track.
Like so scared
in the car and go like,
I'm wearing a helmet.
I'm strapped in five point harness,
I've got a Hans device,
there's a roll cage.
I'll be fine.
My grandfather before he went,
and that's his wife on the right sign,
looks thrilled and that picture,
he's very happy.
Why should he not be blessed as long as Viagara exists?
We're all good.
Fucking,
he's great,
man.
Thank you for that time Bob.
And she's smart.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I love it when people,
when exactly life wins wins.
He's a sweetheart.
He's having fun wounds.
Use Food.
Youtube comments are number four,
six,
five,
two,
nine,
eight.
Yeah.
Well,
it's just,
it's unfortunate.
Yup.
There's,
there's people out there that I have so much horrifying,
are fucking culture sets a really terrible precedent based on the people that
appear on the front page as a fucking TMZ dude.
It certainly does.
The set,
isn't it?
Well,
I think we're fascinating,
fascinating and really stupid.
People are fascinating and undeniable ways,
even as smart folks,
and you're obsessed with Farrah.
Abraham because she is so out of touch.
Who's that?
I don't know who that is.
That teen mom,
Dad,
I made it very obvious anal porno and it's like,
oh no,
we were dating and it leaked and it's,
you know,
oh,
but you got $1 million.
You know,
really young people,
they get thrust into the camera like that.
I can't imagine the kind of pressure and especially if you don't necessarily
have your shit and all this
teen mom show and you have to provide for your child and this is like a lot of
weirdness to that too.
When I was in high school,
that kind of television,
some of it he didn't.
In certain ways it,
it's,
it's almost impossible at for to not be right because it's impossible for you to
be a teenager and to be able to make up your mind whether or not you want the
whole world to be able to see you for the rest of your life.
I don't think even understand what you're doing.
They're not thinking through it.
Their parents,
let me just rephrase that.
I don't think I would have understood what I was doing.
Right.
I know I wouldn't have understood what I was doing and I wouldn't have wanted
that on television.
Right.
I know that ever.
But that's me.
I mean maybe some people don't care and it's not that big of a deal and it
helps.
It gives them money and it helps them get through.
Helps me and I kind of get that it can provide for him.
But,
but fame was fame the end game for you because fame is the end game for them?
Yeah.
Well it's not,
I don't know if it's the end game.
The only game they've got to play all day.
All that matters is the fame.
It's the only game they've got to play.
Do you know what I'm saying?
It's like there's meth heads and fucking Alabama.
The amount of reaction they can get from fame is so much greater than the amount
of reaction that they can get from getting really good at a craft or really good
at an occupation are really good at,
you know,
becoming rising to the top of their field or suck a lot of Cox in a reality show
and drink whiskey through a funnel that's connected to your asshole and you're
the life of the party.
And then all of a sudden everybody wants to know you and you're going to be at
the fucking club opening in Vegas.
You know?
I mean,
that's really how we rocket.
Yeah.
And so you know,
you look at you like,
why did I get a phd and this motherfucker makes $1 million a year on Jersey
shore.
What's happening?
I ran,
happened for Lacey at the fucking Hollywood Roosevelt and asked him if it was,
you know,
he is who's at the fat guy from Jackass.
Oh,
okay.
Hey guys,
the token fat guy.
What happened to him?
I,
you know,
he would do horrible things for 5000.0 my God,
they did.
I ask you things like that and I would ask him,
I,
the first thing I says,
dude,
was it worth it?
And he goes,
no,
just as straight as a fucking air.
No.
Well those jackass guys with with day to a lot of like stuff that can get you
really,
really hurt.
You know?
And I know that
Joe Rogan,
but there's some things like Johnny,
what's his face?
Not Johnny Knoxville.
After he became famous,
after we did movies,
Johnny Knoxville stood right in front of a bull and let that pull launching in.
I put a blindfold on,
he was already in front of the book.
He was already rich.
He was already a movie star that's doing legitimate dukes of Hazzard and fucking
had a bull charge him in the chest.
So fucking crazy.
And he's a dad and he's like 40 he was trying to be letting these euro's launch
them through the air.
Yeah,
I was trying to like keep with it,
but it's such a good idea.
The idea.
What if Johnny Knoxville,
it's like fucking Jagger.
He's like 50 get kicked in the nuts.
Oh my God.
Mick Jagger's.
Another weird thing though,
God,
I don't,
I don't want to go pay to see Mick Jagger perform.
Why?
Because he's so
old.
It's like rock and roll is not not to be performed by old people.
I not like I'll listen to old rolling stones is brilliant.
Some of them in the 60s your effort,
but I'm not going to go to staples center and watch the rolling.
Where's the cut off?
Just not got off.
The cutoff is just when it feels weird because I just got two nights of Pearl
Jam in November.
I'm fucking site.
That's a low brow.
Within the parameter was in parameters.
I don't agree with Todd.
Go See Mick Jagger at staples.
Without a doubt.
It's the only thing that I would do.
The only reason why I would not is the parking.
That would be my concern.
If somebody could tell him.
I know.
Yeah.
My concern would be parking here at if I could eat fucking getting out of this
things.
It's such a pain that dick man,
those giant line fucking,
I'll use the subway.
Joe Take the metro to do that [inaudible] center.
I'm not kidding.
Like driving places like parking lots,
your gt three but this motherfucker,
this this old lady looking dude.
It can't be,
it's probably not even a real pictures.
It's probably a wax figure.
They got hit with a fucking lighter.
That liberty.
He was skydiving and they took his face and put it him.
That's not Jeremy Clarkson in an aerial Adam and mister car guy.
No,
that it's,
it's just,
it's like that Old Lady in Playboy magazine that grandmother naked that would
open the door with her tits touching the ground.
It's just weird to hear Mick Jagger playing.
I can't get no satisfaction
talking about how that playboy,
I want to see that guy.
That's a cartoon.
Not a real,
I don't want us to want to see that guy before he expired.
He said historical figure and it's a nostalgia thing,
but it's not a historical figure in rock and roll for sure.
Like real.
The real band is behind the fucking stage playing the song.
No,
I do not even that.
I wouldn't fucking type shit.
Grassy knoll type shit.
Slam it on the rain.
I don't know.
Mick Jagger sounded like backstage.
I can't imagine that would be true.
I can't imagine that they would allow that.
I agree.
But here's the thing.
I,
I grew up on the east coast.
I saw Bruce Springsteen in an outdoor concert with 2000 people before born to
run.
We listened to him on the radio all the time.
Wow.
That must have been wild.
If slower born to run.
That's how old I am.
This is just like 1973 Nice God in Rock Creek Park and Washington DC is no
denying.
Did Bruce Springsteen was and is still a bad motherfucker then staples center?
No,
no.
He is.
He's still is.
But then as it as it as a performance space,
they opened staples center.
All my buddies,
like we
got to go see Springsteen staples centers opening.
We got all these special tickets.
We went to see him.
It's socked and he played his heart out.
It wasn't his fault.
Whose fault was it?
The acoustic suck.
Oh Wow.
They fixed,
let's hope so.
Yeah,
a little bit.
But he's,
he says suck.
I just mean it was loud and crowded.
Oh,
he means it was a concert.
You meaning it sucked as an experience for you.
Correct.
Okay.
Bruce Bruce is Bruce.
Bruce will always be the boss.
He's like,
he's amazing.
He's unbelievable.
He's drunk.
He's going change.
He's drugs full wavering in and out like I am with Janea,
yellow Russian.
I can drink.
By the way,
Danny,
if you listen to this,
I'm just fucking around your brilliant actor and it's just a joke.
I've done bad TV shows too.
It's all good,
homie.
Aye,
you very much Danny.
Aiello much respect.
You're a bad mother fucker.
As an actor,
how do you come back from a bad TV show?
Well,
it's hard to get a hit TV show now.
If someone puts them on something with some really good writing.
I mean,
we looked at the bottom line with actors is if you don't give them something
good to sink their teeth into,
they never going to have a good show.
It's impossible.
No one actor personality.
I've done some acting,
but when I did it,
I only did it because I couldn't believe that anybody who's going to put me on
television because it was never anything.
I planned it out.
What did you actually act in?
You acted it was on us.
I was on two sitcoms.
Um,
one of them's called hardballs,
a baseball show.
That was terrible.
And then another one was called news radio and that was for a news radio's
that's a real,
she was radio.
That was a real shock man.
Yeah,
it was on for five years.
And then after I did that,
I was like,
okay,
that's,
that's it with actors.
And I did only acted with Kevin James and a couple of movies,
but just Kevin's my buddy,
you know,
he's good.
He's probably fun,
I guess.
Kevin James,
a great guy,
man.
He's a great guy.
He's a funny motherfucker.
Matt,
Matt's equivocating here.
He's got this,
some Kevin James has.
It's like family environment that he's entertaining in.
You know what I mean?
He's in,
well,
let me tell you something.
It's not an Adam Sandler Sandler go to his house and you go,
oh,
okay,
well yeah,
you make it a lot of money to fucking like Bob Saget it up a little bit.
But the thing is about Kevin,
what I know for Real,
he,
he likes doing those movies.
Yeah,
he really does.
Like,
he seems like a guy with a big heart.
He's a very big sweetheart.
He's a sweetheart.
I mean bone in his body.
He likes to make movies to entertain his own kid.
Absolutely.
But he's always been like fairly,
he was always really clean.
He wasn't married,
he was unknown.
He was always really clean.
We were always good buddies,
but our comedy was always very different.
But he's just,
he's a funny fucking dude.
His standup comedy was Kevin James.
Standup comedy was,
I'm telling you,
I've laughed harder watching him and very few people in my life being in,
being his buddy.
That's fine.
We don't do gigs.
Is it worth watching?
It's hard.
Like the stuff that he does now.
I'm like,
uh,
I think,
I don't know if he's,
if he's done a special on a while,
I'm sure he has something.
But when,
when I was,
when I was friends with him,
it's like he was coming up and he would,
when Kevin goes crazy,
like when he would go like get really angry,
something,
he had this bit about Poland,
his girl pull his car up to where his girlfriend was and she goes to grab the
door handle before it unlocks it and it cancels it out and he can't get her to
let go and he fucking screaming.
He gets red in the face,
they cancel each other out.
Could y'all could talk over and over again and he gets fucking crazy.
I don't want even paraphrase the big cause it's so funny picture and Kevin James
His face getting redder and angry and actually it's funny,
it goes crazy.
We had a lot of fun together.
We did.
Kevin and I will always be friends.
We did a lot of gigs together,
like coming up when we were both essentially like our first couple of years of
actually being professionals.
We were both like pal around together.
How many cities would you tour when you did that?
It's just like 10 or or depend like most of the time when I was east coast
based,
I stuck on the east coast because that's where I lived and I didn't do,
the only time I did a road gigs was I would get flown into like these really
shitty shitty colleges and like Olivet,
Michigan,
we would fly on a propeller plane.
I didn't know where to tell you.
It was a private plane and then told you that you had three stopovers.
They would give you off the mail.
A couple of chickens and I would get a rental car and I would have to drive to
the location and I had,
I had a map.
Oh,
okay.
There was no navigation systems back then and the injections that gave you were
always wrong.
Siri,
who shall we?
So some weird motherfucker in the middle.
Yeah.
I've,
I've had some crazy experiences like who do you like to see if you can go see,
see what I like to see.
There's so many people now.
This is like one of the best times ever.
Really good time for comedy.
Stand up.
Your Buddy Brian was hilarious.
Callen yeah,
we want to see Bryan County,
Washington.
He was awesome.
He was hilarious.
We landed early and Joe says,
you want to go see this show?
I think fuck yes,
let's go.
Chris Porter.
No,
he's fucking great.
I just saw,
I just saw him at the comedy store in California.
There's a lot of really funny guys now.
It's getting better and better like all the time.
It's very exciting.
I have all these in Florida.
I was fucking,
my friend gave me a,
a murse like immerse a Lamborghini mercy ago and I thought you meant like a man
purse.
I was going to bond with you like my fanny pack.
You've got to put those up on [inaudible].
They'll go wear a fanny pack all day Sun.
You'll Goldberg Rock switchback blowing up.
I have no problem admitting I wear a fanny pack blowing up last week on the
show,
on the show,
I wore a fanny pack when I went out squatch and,
and um,
I should have pointed out that I have a swatch,
sweet fanny pack squashes.
When you go looking for bigfoot Sasquatch,
they call it squatch and you would actually,
I'm actually in the know that's watching Jesus watching for the teeth.
Joe's gone squats and Matt,
we came really close to mean finding bigfoot.
Yeah.
While you were questioning everything,
were you questioning squatch is that yes.
Yeah.
We went and I'll tell you really worth questioning.
I think we've pretty much established,
oh no,
we have,
this is why it's known.
There's only one reason why it's worth question.
The only one for me,
and that's that it used to be a real animal,
100%,
no doubt about it.
It was a gigantic kitchens animal,
but have no a hundred thousand years within the last hundred thousand years,
it was an eight to 10 foot tall,
gigantic primate looking thing that may or may not have been bipedal depending.
Apparently.
I said by people before,
but then some people on the rogue and board pointed out that that's actually in
dispute.
It's based on the shape of the jaw.
Apparently they believe that the draw is shaped in a way that indicates that
that thing stood up,
right.
Not like a shape of a gorilla,
right where it's over on,
on,
on fall forward.
None of those people who say they've seen it.
I've actually seen it and that's what I'm saying is that it was a real laugh.
It was a real animal that lived in the same area where people came from,
where people came on the Bering Strait lands shrimp,
the bank straight,
that's Asia and that's exactly what these gigantic picture there was a split and
some point in evolution is that they died off and most likely they died off.
Most likely.
There's nothing up there,
most likely people full of shit.
Most likely people see things in the dark,
most likely.
If you look at,
you know,
if you want to like outcomes,
raise the shit out of it,
but you have to wonder about this sheer mass of the Pacific northwest.
First of all,
if you fly over that thing,
it will make you shit your pants.
You can't believe how many fucking trees there are up there.
And you know,
no one's on there.
I'm going there tomorrow,
man.
Mallet marine near his fucking faggot.
I'm driving by.
I'm doing 500 miles off road.
I'm doing the Washington discovery,
uh,
Washington back under discovery.
We're doing 500 miles on dirt to what?
Diagonally across the state of war.
The guy pack just in case.
Give me the fanny pack.
He need a good solid camera man.
You can't be fucking with your iPhone.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Good solid 12 we're bringing like of course your film at Gopros or you got go
pros all over the county.
You get an h fucking amateur hour son.
We're way beyond Gopros.
Five d mark two and three mounts to a car fuck cab or over kill.
No proper cinematic quality out changeable lenses.
He geeked out on me.
You hurt my feelings.
This is why your camera's on cars.
You're making cable shows that I'm working on the Internet,
which is the future because I fucking shoot cars properly and networks
and the internet.
And the real question is,
now that I have Joe cornered on a fucking microphone,
can I make a film with your car?
Yeah,
yeah,
we could just something she had to film
because Shark Works [inaudible] car word.
It has to be fun car man.
Pick our road.
You know the race,
the road we talked.
No,
no,
no.
First of all ever say don't say it
on the air.
Never say it on the air.
Right.
Well we'll take it to a track and have some fun with it.
That's what we fun car.
It's really fun.
It's glued to the ground too,
so it's so alive.
That card,
like it's so low driver though is daily.
Come on.
You don't have a fucking daily,
I have other cars,
but I have an m three a new,
a new one.
You know I got another one,
I had one and I got an a not a VA.
Yeah,
the same Da da,
but it's not the Turbo Charge v six right.
That's exactly,
that doesn't come out.
I got,
I got a new one because I loved it so much.
That's like a traffic car.
Those cars,
cars,
it's a perfectly balanced car.
It's fast as you ever needed to be.
It merges.
It does whatever you do.
If you're not driving like an asshole and it's,
I have a double comforts of my own ambition.
If you're in La,
you have an excuse
and we were like texting back and forth and you were saying that it was bombed
you out with the new gt three and the lack of paddle or a manual.
I won't buy it.
Well,
here's the problem is that you and your Porsche parked outside.
You have spent however long you've had that car,
daily driving,
v more most perfect manual transmission there is.
Okay,
so your car,
I drive a lot of cars that drive like 200 cars a year.
That's the best that stick gets.
Now.
The nine nine one with that seven speed they have,
it sucks.
I've heard that from the
paddles or a terrible shift.
I don't think there should be those two options.
Let's think there's six the shifter choice,
go back to the same kid.
Figure out how to fit that nine nine seven,
six speed manual gearbox and your stupid nine nine one or something and go fuck
yourself.
That's what they need to do.
Go back to a six Pete,
I don't need seven speed.
Stupid.
What am I trying to save pennies on gas mileage.
Stop being silly.
You know,
once you really want the neck transmissions,
you fuck got seven miles a gallon on my car.
The only way to get a step up from what you have right now is a tick your motor
and putting in a Cayman.
Oh yeah.
That's the fucking gate.
The four weeks game leader came in is the game over.
That's a game ender.
That's the Porsche had the balls to actually make that car.
It would be fucking tremendous.
Is No one who would buy nine 11 nine 11 to the end of the nine Olympia over to
shark works do that.
Will they take a a gt three engine and put it in a Cayman?
You know,
who else will it be?
Bi Autumn who I promised I would blog.
Yeah,
because the guys who made that,
uh,
was 85.
Is that what it was?
That's what I'm going to tell you.
It was almost brought it.
I almost brought it,
but I have to get on a flight at 9:00 AM tomorrow morning,
so I can't bring it back to Huntington.
Well,
we'll do another next time we do a podcast bringing it to my podcast.
I would love to,
but why don't they put a Sunroof in the Cayman?
Um,
you could buy a Boxster which says no.
Why would you do that when you have a box?
I love the sun roof in my car.
I know you do,
but you know what man,
those buttons and those Boxster s ss,
they go back so fast.
It's like 13 seconds.
I don't want a convertible,
but you're in a car that's like,
it's boxed.
It's such a solid roadster.
I've been in fucking driving a Boxster.
They're great toy.
We,
we hit a weird error right now with cars.
And that the exponential increase of technology that applies to almost
everything in the world,
whether it's laptops or cell phones,
also applies to automobiles and horsepower.
And there's a point of diminishing returns,
right?
And in my opinion,
it seems to lie within this range of like a really like car in 320 horsepower
engine.
And that's where a lot of these guys like that,
uh,
that race car driver that was married to Ashley Judd,
what is his name?
Dario Franchitti.
Yes.
Yeah.
That,
that guy has the sickest 1973 Porsche with a 325 horsepower engine.
Now think about that much in that car so much.
But that doesn't sound like much in the era of 648 horsepower.
Zr One YouTube's fault.
Dude,
I swear to God or your your youtube.
Well forgive me dude.
I live in a world of,
if you can't beat them,
join them.
I got Exxon mobile stock coming out of my fucking ass hole right now because you
know why I make fucking money on it?
That's why you make money on Exxon mobile stock keeps going up going up.
And the buy Exxon stock.
Yeah.
Dude,
I have tons of it because you're,
you're probably the Illuminati or something that makes you,
I mean,
you can't beat them.
Join them.
I'm not going to take part of the world.
They order the same thing.
It's,
it's,
you see a video of a super with 1200 horsepower and then with 1500 horsepower,
right.
When the truth is the limit of modern tire technology is like 600.
That's about where it stops.
Beyond that,
it's like we'll spin or going off a cliff or into a fucking wall or,
you know,
and,
and people talk about all the,
the newest modern super cars that aren't stick shift.
Right.
But you can't have it both ways.
You can't sell somebody a 700 horsepowers stick shift car.
You know why?
Cause will fucking die.
Yeah.
Like you don't want miss bad advertising.
I mean,
imagine,
you know,
if they sold a 500 horsepower fucking gt three Rs to the,
to the public,
well let's go,
let's,
well,
let's start breaking that down because that really is what they're doing.
If you buy a Zr one,
you buy a corvette Zr one you can walk into any dealership,
but if you have the cash and it's a lot of money,
but it's worth it
to about 120 yeah,
and they're fucking worth every penny.
Yeah.
It's the bargain of the supercar world.
640 horsepower,
zero to 60 on a stick in three seconds in first gear.
You don't just shift gears.
He just dumped a clutch,
stomp the gas and watch this first gear.
Dump it.
Easy Button for launch control.
It's just built in.
So you put it in first,
push the clutch,
shitty flat.
You want to push a button?
I don't want launch control.
That shit's ridiculous.
With 648 horsepower car.
Oh,
I launched 1100 horsepower Nissan Gtr.
I lit up all four tires through three years.
And you know what?
The guy who owned the car said he was going to go for more.
He was,
he wanted to take the car back and get more horsepower.
This is how boring the Nissan Gtr is.
That 1100 horsepower.
Does this sound like you're fucking,
I'll extension to,
you know,
to me it's a,
it's an extension of the man's need for technological innovation.
It's the same thing.
It's just,
it's transferred into gears and horsepower and you know,
handling and did the Newburg ring times and
Caicos to me about bigger is better.
I want more.
No,
I think it's just foolishness.
It's like bodybuilder mentality.
You know,
body builds up a 30 lb.
Women can choke you out.
I'll just do is hang on for three weeks.
I better run out of gas.
Right.
I mean,
would you rather own a car with your heart and earn money?
Would you rather own a car that went fast on paper or felt fast when you drove
it felt fast when you drove it for sure that that was [inaudible] that was Dario
is rationalization or explanation for his car.
He was talking about his car being like 2000 something pounds,
325 horsepower,
which is a lot for,
and it,
it's a dream.
It's like this is what he enjoys.
No balance,
no power.
Assisted steering system powers a stupidly fast car.
Yeah.
And Weird fast,
you know,
like you feel like if you're going 40 fills or you're going to 80
that's what I'm about.
Scary fucking drive.
Like a fun and you're safe to drive a fucking coon tosh.
Oh Geez.
I mean you could die at any second.
It's like a plane that doesn't have wings or I drove,
you know this thing,
the Hennessey Venom Gt.
I saw that video yellow one.
No,
that's had a yellow one.
They did have a yellow one.
Top Gear magazine did a thing with it with yellow coffee.
Yeah.
It's ridic.
I mean they're,
you know Steven Tyler has one of these things we're talking about old rock
stars.
This fucking bones are made of whatever they're made up.
However baby.
Yeah.
Whenever you replace
the bones or baby powder in straws,
lightly taped together.
Yeah.
You know,
and I'm driving this thing and I'm going,
I go zero to 200 in 15 seconds.
Oh my God.
And it's like you are selling this to,
you were staying in Tyler.
That's the kind of car you'd want to like fuck it.
I'm Steven Tyler.
Exactly.
That car is all about power to weight ratio in the saddle.
Again,
he deserves some credit,
another check,
big deal.
200 miles an hour.
That's something Tyler had them put a this crazy radio system in the car or they
added like 80 kilograms to the car,
so they gave it more horsepower to offset the radio.
That's okay because it has learned that even hundred why would that even fact at
1300 watts need to go?
That's too crazy.
Every,
every kilogram counts.
Yeah.
I think I'm driving enjoyment is what's important and it's not about being a
fucking complete total maniac and that's what people really miss out on.
Like you don't understand,
like you can drive at a normal safe speed and not be a dick head.
Enjoy driving.
Yeah.
These are fun cars.
We have live in a cool time.
There was the mom with Baltimore.
My son was like 12 and he said to me,
we're going somewhere.
It's like dead is driving fun.
And it was a really,
I hadn't even thought about it before and I said I hadn't thought about it in a
long time since I started driving and I said,
yeah,
actually dry your spot and it should be fun car man.
If you're in a fun car.
Driving is fun.
It's also like why isn't it any more like why was it at one point in time?
Why isn't it anymore too many stop lights,
movies like vanishing point and the first Canon ball and shit.
It's like love vanishing point.
Able to like run from the cops.
I mean can you even fathom trying to run from the cops?
Smokey and the bandit ran from the cops in a car and sometimes they would,
when you run from cops,
helicopters,
they're tasing you.
It's on youtube.
Like you could run and get away.
At one point we had a four 40 with a six pack on open throttle,
a fire
in a 15 second quarter mile,
get away cowboy boots and a Jean jacket and the sweat and it was his beard.
You've ever run from the cops show?
No.
Did you get away?
I got pulled over by the way.
I got away once and then I ran once and I got caught and then let go.
Whoa.
That's some good Tony.
Alex Roy.
I got caught doing an Alex Roy's BMW.
I'm going to have the German police department,
Soul German guy.
They know about Alex Roy.
Joe.
He's one of those coast to coast guys and Trans Continental set of records.
I mean coast to coast.
Alex Roy is a fundamentally can you drive from New York to La?
It's a thing to it and he did it and he wrote a book and he's dangerous.
Big trick was recommend.
BMW tarted up like a German police feel for the actual being more than you did
storm chasers.
Yeah,
for the actual run it with storm chasing.
He later went to German police livery but we were driving that car in South
Carolina and it has all kinds of in it.
Right.
So like all kinds of like electronics,
like really crazy stuff.
So we're going with the helicopter look spotting for police cars,
that kind of stomach 60 through South Carolina.
I'm driving right tail lights out.
No.
You had to tail light cutout.
So we've no tail lights.
No brake light dark.
Isn't that what you call it?
Yeah,
it's like a driving submarine.
Zooming a buck 60 silent and it has night vision so he could see a cop in the
trees.
Oh my God.
So we cop was in the trees.
Yeah cause you could see his,
their engines are idling.
So you can see the heat signature through Jackie Gleason.
Oh the trees are ahead
ahead.
He's hiding in the trees.
So he gets us.
But we're full dark at this point.
So I tried to run and we got off the first exit and turn left.
Right.
Because if you're running from the cops you always turn left.
80% of cops go right because the right is the easier turn.
Oh you'd always go left if you're running from the cops.
We go strategy all you then make another left onto some crowed and it was like
be advised,
hurry,
like get out and got out and started pissing.
I'm looking at the fucking left to go into traffic.
Yeah.
So you always want to make the harder term,
which is the left,
the very least.
It buys you some time and in this case it didn't work well.
The cop came over and was like,
you know what?
What is this car were you doing
right now?
How about this?
Pull the fuck over and let the cop arrest you.
Don't go left.
Sorry.
Vice pro.
The best consumer advice would be it'll cost you even more when they catch you
probably these days.
They've got drones.
Probably have a drone in your car that you're not really aware of that we'll
find out about next year in the rental car they do.
The new Bradley Manning released,
released these documents.
The PS,
all that shit is I now have a lawyer that I have to pay like a thousand dollars
a month just to keep me fucking driving.
That.
Shay catches up with you.
What happened?
I've gotten many,
many,
many.
You have a radar detector that only works some of the time.
This is an important message for the young people.
Learn from Matt Farah.
Exactly.
Do that.
Will you lose your license or costs you a lawyer?
A guy in a tie.
If you'll give me shit because I don't like street drift.
Like Chris Harris,
like he's in like a foreign country.
You know what I imagine I went up on fucking Mulholland.
It started street drifting on video.
How quickly would I be in jail for that shit?
Five minutes.
Like right away.
He's street drifts in an old Porsche around sheep.
I'm not joking.
New Zealand.
Perfect,
perfect.
Perfect.
Nine 11 by Chris Harris.
This motherfucker takes this 1971 something Porsche with a 300 horsepower
engine.
Wow.
He built it like before singer was doing these reconstructions.
He put like modern chassies had Tuttle do the full race suspension and full
like,
like inside Alicante total rally cage.
I went to the trial shop in Europe,
in England.
It was crazy.
I would geek out if I went there,
so I never met him before.
I didn't know he was,
Hey Matt,
this is Richard.
Oh Nice to meet you.
Would you like to try my new dog box?
And he had a nine 11 when the fucking dog box said it.
Oh,
here's Chris Sweat this,
this,
this crazy fuck those white things.
Those are sheep and this dude is going stir around this corner.
That is a hot look like
beautiful.
Yeah.
That's a night.
What is that 71 what he did was he put a,
a modern engine and a more modern gearbox in and still air cooled air cooled to
be tweaked.
The suspension.
Oh yeah,
totally.
Completely.
But what it essentially is is the best you could do of every year.
That's gorgeous.
It's crazy.
Well,
you know what it is.
It's like there's some call to nostalgia when we look at his classic show and
you get him going sideways.
I love watch this.
There's some called in his style Jah.
Like when you see like a classic shape,
watch this,
watch this.
Oh,
kind of balls.
You have to have the street drift.
Whether it's sheep and look,
he's Keegan.
He got key cut the curb.
This is like,
this is like the a ballet move.
It's like a pure wet.
What would the special of the car,
that car,
that car was under 2000 pounds.
Wow.
And it's like somebody's car,
like I don't know how you get a this skill and be the balls to borrow someone's
car.
No,
that's his car.
Well that would know that was his,
but he does it with car to borrow someone's car and then Hawk it backwards into
a fucking,
I say,
governor,
you don't mind if I take your car.
Did you hear about this poor fucking auto journalist who was driving a Porsche
nine 17 race car and blew the gearbox?
It was it,
I can't remember the guy's name.
And it was a journalist or drew.
He was driving a bar,
you know,
a million dollar Porsche.
Wow.
Lou,
the gear.
How did he do?
Is it his fault?
Apparently missed a shift,
but I hear that's all it takes is a ship,
which was like just shit.
Where's Ralph Nader?
Exactly.
It's fucking thing's a piece of shit.
But the old gonna blow up like a pinto.
The fucking owner of the car sued the guy in the bankruptcy.
Oh,
let me literally sued the guy into bankruptcy.
So I that kind of shit.
I'm reading and going.
Yeah.
And you know the audiences like you didn't fucking drifted you fucking pussy
going,
this guy's,
someone's going to sue me out of business if I do that.
Did you ever see the video of Eddie Griffin crashing and
crashing and Enzo into this cement barrier and it's of a brother can't drive?
Yeah.
Yeah,
it was.
It was.
It was horrific.
Remember when that bottle was full?
Yeah.
This whiskey,
it used to be in that bottle.
This whiskey is fantastic.
They're not Todd's a whiskey fan.
Call a cab son.
That's what I recommend.
Drinking bottled waters.
There's pee break at some point there.
Here it is.
Oh Jesus.
Watch this again.
By the way,
for folks who don't know what we're looking at,
this is $1 million car.
He hit him and rigid legitimate million dollar car and if I recall,
it was understeer understeer into a wall.
Complete under stairs.
Oh
Nasty.
It was in the videos.
A total complete catastrophic loss.
Control the car.
You want to grab your balls when that happens,
because that hurts so much.
It was totaled.
It was,
but as is the case,
what's a $4 million cars?
It's never really total.
Sorry.
A guy actually bought that car at salvage at bought
the body.
You ever see the p four five Jim Glick and houses?
He re bodied an Enzo p four five no,
check it out.
Look up the p four slash five so he got the original body from that.
When everybody's like an encyclopedia,
he took that wrecked Enzo,
put twin turbos on it,
and then they went and ran Bonneville with it.
I think it did like two 30 or two something at Bonneville.
So the dog dish fucking wheels on it and shit like a Bonneville Enzo from that
wrecked mess.
So what,
how did I go?
Did like the insurance coverage and the guy like cell,
the body of it all,
they wrecked so many cars during.
That's The p four five right there.
That's what $5 million gets you.
Oh my God.
That's insane.
Looking.
Yeah,
that's a fair deal.
Uh,
this is a guy named Jim Glicken house,
who's from the town where I grew up,
who has lots of money and likes a vintage race cars and had Pininfarina re body.
His Enzo.
The design was by Jason Castree Yoda who designed the Freud five,
nine,
nine Maserati granturismo.
Um,
this was 23 years old dude.
The Guy designed this that is the most like Super Dick Looking car.
That's a game over it's game over game over one of a kind Ferrari.
Yeah.
That is ridiculous.
Looking is wild looking.
It is.
It's really cool.
Like it's Kinda Nsx see like with the hood.
Yeah.
And then you know,
like it,
it reminds you of like a lot of different cars and so a lot of reuse from
vintage fur like late sixties Ferrari race cars.
Yeah.
Ferrari's a completely different statement.
That's that super ball or statement.
So funny though.
If they are to plan my day Gig,
I rent exotic cars.
My company's called Gotham dream cars.
And what kind of cars you get in Ferrari's ma'am?
Bars.
Do you ever get manuals for ours of the stick?
See in the history of our company,
we've had 97 cars,
seven of them have been manual transmissions.
All seven had been totaled compared to one out of 90 of the other.
So no,
we don't buy stick cars anymore.
That's hilarious.
People can't drive silly.
It starts with a hey man,
watch this and ends up smashing into some kind of stationary object ends up like
that Ferrari.
There's a Gotham dream cars website.
Was that story?
I don't remember.
It was Beverly hills,
I think.
I feel like it was Beverly hills.
Somebody uh,
parked their car,
the valet,
it was a Ferrari.
It was a four or five a and a thank and some Valet Chi decided to take it
sideways around a corner and smash right into a parked car in half.
That's fucking great.
It's that,
I mean,
what,
what those things are is so alien to the,
the uh,
person who hasn't driven a normal person cannot comprehend how fast the car like
that is.
There are time machines.
You know I remember that was the,
when I,
the first car that I realized what it was,
that nine nine six turbo,
that was the first year.
They were really fast,
very fast car and really weird like the four wheel drive was weird.
It was just like wood grip to the ground.
You could feel the power shifting around.
I didn't know that was for,
yeah,
they started with a nine nine three the nine nine three the last,
the air cooled cars.
The turbo was a four wheel drive cars.
Those cars are going for right now.
A Lot,
right fucking nine nine three turbos are a hundred grand.
Nine nine three turbo s's are $300,000 the 903 terrible answers,
so sweet without the little vents on the side.
The back wheels,
Seinfeld's got one baby blue fucking boss.
Every bad ass Porsche that say,
here's the 73 gt three Rs.
He has everything.
I'd been in his garage.
That's a lot of good money.
That's that fuck.
That's called Seinfeld Seinfeld money right there.
He's got the Porsche,
which is the oldest known original,
unrestored Porsche in existence.
The vin number was eight.
Oh my God.
That's not going to restore it.
Is he
like that 73 Rs?
Correct me if I'm wrong.
It's worth a stupid amount of money,
isn't it?
300 to 400 probably drives that on the street.
It just takes it out.
He's got insurance.
Well,
that guy Glicken house,
who's got the p four five that I showed you,
he has a 68 gt 40 that ran at Sebring that he converted to a street car and has
40,000 street miles on it.
My good friend,
he's got a low law that he's got street miles on.
He's nuts.
He's great.
I love it.
I love guys like that.
Yeah.
They use their car.
I bought a Lamar prototype,
put air conditioning in it,
call it a street car and he's got 50,000 street on it.
That's bad us.
That's,
that's the right way to roll.
It's not a hot wheel.
He's having a ride every day.
Everywhere he goes.
He's on a ride.
Yeah.
It's not as simple as always an adventure.
And here I am in my fucking voltage is like a sensory deprivation chamber,
which everyone else said I had to talk to you about.
Those volts are super quiet.
Right.
There's silence.
Just dead silent bolts are genius though.
Like electricity.
The thing about electric cars is you have all power like that.
There's no power curve.
It's on or it's off,
right?
Yeah.
I've driven golf carts,
so I'd imagine it just,
but yeah,
it's right through there.
And to the right,
I would imagine it'd be like a super powerful golf cart.
They're unbelievably fast.
Yeah.
They don't have like a gear to go through.
It's just one gear.
Yep.
I've seen that with the Teslas.
Yup.
I've never,
I've,
we saw,
um,
uh,
that one Tesla s that our friend from the show had them then.
Yeah.
And um,
the,
yeah,
the guy who was here who drove it around entirely around the country.
Right.
He hit every single point around the country.
The border.
Yeah.
And,
uh,
the,
our other friend in DC that had one too,
but I've seen the,
uh,
the old one or the sports car one small.
Oh yeah,
that's just a d r And d and p I guess fast as hell.
It's like a lotus with electricity.
Yeah.
It's a weird thing.
Like the go fast electric thing.
I just,
it
doesn't like,
you know,
you're used to your car like ramping up.
But uh,
it's that natural progression thing that we,
we've come accustomed to.
And also in these electrical engines they go,
oh,
you don't have to do that.
One gear is good.
And he's like,
what do you mean here?
Here's good duck and one gear.
We good,
we're electric,
we've got a whole totally different thing we're doing.
It's like a complete transformation.
Yeah.
And because yeah,
you have the feel,
the touch,
the electro mechanic ability to go through one,
two,
three,
four,
five,
six and now it's just on or it's off.
Well,
yeah,
that's the thing that people really appreciate about the older cars.
Like a bill burr was here once and he had this,
uh,
God,
I want to say the year,
but I think it was a 50s pickup truck and beautiful.
And Bill was so proud of this car.
I mean,
bill is a bill's in an ace of a guy.
He's a really hilarious standup comedian and a cool guy.
And he likes like interesting shit.
Bill Burr,
fucking dude,
Bill.
The other greatest takedowns I've ever heard him versus fucking Philadelphia.
How?
Yeah,
that was awesome.
Did he had a shifter on the floor?
No,
no,
no.
I believe the shift.
It was on the tree.
The tree.
He,
Bill Burr.
I don't,
I don't know the,
I don't know the make or the year.
It's a really old pickup truck that he actually drives around.
Really?
Yeah.
He was so proud of it.
He brought it to the ice house last time we did a podcast together and he pulls
up in this thing.
It's got the old breaks,
old suspension,
old everything.
Oh,
it's sketchy as fuck.
Well,
I think he's just,
you know,
slow and steady wins the race,
but I think he does.
Yeah,
yeah.
He really,
he just loved the fact that he's driving this thing.
He loves the fact that he's in this,
this really ancient like,
I mean if you want to be,
you know,
environmentally friendly,
keeping a car like that on the road is way more efficient than buying a fucking
Prius or whatever.
Don't participate in the new car.
Fucking Todd.
He says,
but I don't know.
I'm not here to be an environmentalist.
I bought a volt for very selfish reasons to save my own ass money.
I my commute to Prius's so I'm not saying holier than thou.
Does it let you get in the car lane or anything?
The carpooling,
carpooling Solo.
That's enough reason.
Reason enough.
Prius doesn't do that cause it's all hybrid.
But like a Tesla does
Tesla.
When Tesla volt,
if I had more money I would have bought it the ugliest car on the planet.
The leaf will do that.
I think it's heinous.
So all the uh,
electrical,
it's really hilarious when a Prius owner,
his shit on the way or another.
That's right.
I know you're drunk.
Seriously.
Now that's when you,
you're drunk.
Prius is there,
uh,
the like the most simple form ever for a car.
The dog,
me,
don't worry about what it looks like.
The volt is better.
You know why the Prius has shaped that way?
I agree with you.
You know why the Prius has shaped that way Todd?
Drag Coefficient.
All right.
How about this mother fucker?
You want to fucking talk track called,
do you know what the drag coefficient?
No,
it's 0.26.
Okay.
You know what else has a drag Coefficient and 0.26 corvette stingray,
Mercedes east 63 AMG has a drag coefficient of 0.26.
One of those cars is looking to live in New York City.
Is that a faster car?
Like what is that?
570 horsepower?
Hey Matt,
what's the price differential?
Uh,
several dollars.
Yeah,
right,
right.
But I drove a diesel Mercedes e three 50 diesel from Mexico to Oregon on one
tag.
Mercedes are brilliant.
I'm not talking about the car and the engineering and an overactive and
slippery.
Where's your car is unattractive in slippery.
It is.
And my corvette also attract and it's cheap and it works slippery through the
air drag coefficient.
I also wax it and k while you were doing things with it,
but guess what?
This is.
This is where engineering genius.
I have a 2003 Prius.
My daughter drives.
It's got 190,000 miles original battery original every grade dude,
and it still gets like 40 miles a gallon.
If somebody else drives it,
not you.
You're the,
you're a hundred miles an hour and a Prius guy.
Fucking hate those too.
I've seen miles an hour and a Prius guys,
the buddy of mine goes,
hey,
these things are fast.
I said yesterday,
Oh,
oh,
most should be stopped
fast isn't enough fast to the imagination for a Prius a hundred miles an hour.
I remember how we were talking about how it feels like it's gonna fall apart.
Yes,
exactly right.
The pharmacy will feel solid because you ever see he's a volt fan.
Do you ever see the episode of top here?
Would they went around the track with a m three and a Prius and all the m three
had to do is keep up with the Prius drivers fat.
The Prius goes as fast as they can in the m three keeps helping at the end.
Got better gas mileage.
I believe that it's hilarious.
My Corvette,
500 horsepower I get 35 miles ago on the highway in that car.
That's amazing.
It's funny.
Low drag coefficient and in sixth gear at 80 I'm turning 1300 rpm.
Wow.
Super gear head radius.
We are geeking out on call.
You say it's not Kiki to the average person who's not a car gig.
It's extremely deep listening to your show when you talk about MMA and now it's
nothing wrong with it.
Hey,
this is nuts.
Listen,
I'm not saying we should stop out.
What it is is what it is.
We're dorks.
Let's just face it.
Do that.
I own I own Dork.
I don't own nothing wrong with being a Dork,
but we're card dorks.
It's fair.
It happened here.
Here it's affects nothing wrong with it.
Do you or do you in your cars or have the perfect car?
Is your,
is your car perfect for your,
this cool by the way?
They move here.
Yeah,
fire up.
Um,
I like,
um,
I like older cars.
Uh,
there's something I like about older cars.
It's very different than,
um,
than newer cars.
I liked the feeling of them.
I liked this,
this idea that this thing came from a different era.
They have a,
there's a like a,
a different air to dry.
The older cars have a permanence about them.
The new cars don't have,
I mean I fucking touch a new car.
When you can press the body panel,
it's flexing.
You're like,
this shit isn't going to be here in fucking 50 years.
Well this is also,
it exists with a,
in a,
in a lot of ways with music as well.
This is an error of cars that are really like,
and that error is the same where I liked the music.
It's the sixties and seventies,
and I don't know what it is.
I don't know what it tastes,
not stretching or the 90 stretches.
It stretches deep into the two thousands.
I mean,
I'm a big fan of the black keys.
I like a lot.
I like all kinds of shit.
I like people,
you know,
people like playing the good things all the time.
And I get into new things.
I mean I know I'll have like a rigid sense,
but if I'm alone,
like I'm in my car,
like I will throw on Voodoo child,
you know,
and um,
I'll crank that shit to this day.
I felt heard that song a billion times.
I have a really hard time with classic rock cause it never fucking change it.
You know what I'm saying?
Doesn't like classic rock is always the same.
It's the same problem I have with like,
nevermind,
nevermind is one of the greatest songs ever made,
but it's the same 13 songs fucking know.
You know,
you have to be completely in the mood for it.
But at a certain point in time,
if it becomes like almost an oversaturation point where there's so much music
out there,
there's so much music that it's like it doesn't,
um,
you don't even,
you almost don't even have to change decades.
Did you,
did you see a sound city Dave girls documentary about the sound city studios,
which is actually not far at all from here.
Jesse,
you like it?
It's dope.
It's a little bit self serving but also totally dope.
I was an audio engineering school so it,
Oh yeah,
me a little bit as well and isn't the,
isn't just the analog ness of it.
Awesome.
It was awesome that he wanted to take the whole board out of there.
I look just the same ridiculous of all the stuff that was made on it.
Like that's,
that's like a lot of the fucking old cars that are working on it.
I think that's why a lot of people love vinyl.
Some people love like vinyl records.
They love like hearing like the scratching and the pops of the needle going over
the black plastic or whatever the fuck that shits me.
Never driven a manual transmission Ferrari.
No,
it's,
that's it.
It's that.
It's why no record imperfections then make it great.
You know,
and,
and they're all very hard to find.
But if you meet someone that has one,
do yourself a favor and try and drive it because the satisfaction of detailing
of fucking manual transmission for Ari is so wonderful that you're like,
why the fuck even if paddles are half a second faster around the track,
why would you want that?
Cause it's that Sionix that click click of the gated shifter and like that's
just such a wonderful analog operation.
Like a watch or something,
you know?
It's,
yeah,
it's got this,
which is why I think the,
um,
the Ford gt is what is the most collectible supercar of modern times because it
has certain things that technology can't make outdated.
That's the problem.
You think about a Ferrari three six,
right?
A 10 year old Ferrari that things a pilot shit.
You drive one today,
it's shifts like,
Ooh,
you know,
it's because the technology is moving as fast as computer technology is,
whereas something that is analog,
we'll be analog forever.
Right?
So the Ford Gt,
right?
Think about this supercharged truck engine,
right way overbuilt,
right aluminum chassis,
manual transmission,
no traction control,
no stability control.
A transmission that can handle three times its horsepower and aerodynamics that
can handle 60 to 70 miles an hour beyond its original top speed.
That car has the makings for the perfect storm of collector car.
Awesome.
Which is why the,
uh,
the Ford Gt,
the Ferrari Enzo in the Mclaren f one or the only collector cars to have
actually appreciated that were built in the last 15 or so years.
It's the perfect storm of collectability than he because it will be what it is.
Yeah.
The modern Ford gt because it would be what it is forever.
Uh,
for our three 60 was awesome in 2003.
Now you drive and you go,
Holy Shit,
this thing's a fucking dinosaur.
But a Ford Gt will always be that your gt three Rs will never feel old because
it shifts as fast as you can shift it.
You know,
it will,
all the cars that have that analog fields with them have a permanence about them
that the latest technology that though this shifts in 80 milliseconds and this
one shifts in 50 milliseconds and I have eight mode traction control and I have
12 mode traction control.
That shit gets,
you know,
that's your hundred and 33 megahertz pentium processor right there.
You know that Shit's worthless in 50 years.
But a stick car will always be a stick car.
This,
I think it's sad that baseline,
I think he got shot on fucking top care.
Todd Joker Rooney.
I think it's sad that they're stopping making them,
but I think it's awesome that American cars are picked up where they've dropped
the ball to think about that.
The Viper,
the vet,
all these,
these are,
they're sticking with it.
All these new American cars have manual transmissions and it makes me want to
get one.
I just got rid of my Shelby.
I had a,
you got rid of it?
Yeah.
I had a gt 500 car.
I'm scared of the convertible scare me.
Cause the chassis was made of Legos.
Was that it was 2011 it was very fast.
The rollbar.
Yeah,
this one.
There's no robot cars.
The best year of the Shelby.
It was a great car.
Newer one is worse.
Have you driven the new one?
It's so fast.
It's so crazy.
Too much.
Too much power.
Crazy.
They went power.
No chassis.
No 40 what did they go to?
They say six 62 but it's putting down like six 30 at the wheels are God.
That's insane.
So what does that have the crank?
She's this crime.
Here's the problem,
right?
Oh my God.
Even within Ford,
right?
You got a car
like the boss,
the boss,
Mustang.
Right,
which is the best Mustang you can buy.
That's a great bargain.
Where they say they
gave them an m three and they take this Mustang.
It better make it better than this m three and they actually did that.
Really?
In terms of dynamically,
yes.
Not In terms of like the leather and shit,
but the way it handles,
the way it moves,
really?
That they're not nice.
Wow.
Why don't they get any love?
They get a lot of love,
man.
Yeah,
but only funnel Dorks,
automotive magazine,
Youtube Dorks.
Who Do you
hear that from?
People that it's like a girl because girls won't blow you because you're driving
one where you go by.
How are you gonna have a three 28 own rims and get a fucking hummer out of that?
Easy.
So it is a different time than when I grew up.
Cause the boss,
yeah,
there's status to IBM.
Does the boss,
Mustang doesn't convey enough street cred or blurred,
right?
Yes,
but not to regular people.
That's interesting.
And then they have the Shelby,
which is Carroll Shelby going right before his,
you know,
all basically on his fucking death bed going.
Now listen here boys,
I want to see me.
Shelby before I die,
does zero to 60 in three and a half seconds.
That Mustang to go 200 mile an hour and I want that motherfucker to have 600
horsepower and it,
it better be the fastest God.
I want all the magazine covers.
I want the fucking magazine and covering.
I want all them car and driver boys sucking my cock.
And I really what to say.
You don't want to put words in his mouth.
And that's what he got.
That's what he got.
He got every magazine cover.
He got fucking Holy Shit.
It does 200.
But what he didn't build is the best driving Mustang he could buy.
Right.
So the best drivers,
the on much lighter.
It was about four 41 or the Shelby you have actually is too much.
It's too crazy in a coupe.
It's okay.
And it's worried about flipping it.
Yeah.
It didn't seem very stable and it just,
it was too easy to sit in this.
It was,
it was a really fun car.
Really Fun.
So I just say that,
uh,
I also,
one of the reasons why I got it,
it's like I wanted to,
I wanted to buy a car from a company that didn't take a check from the
government.
I didn't like,
that's interesting.
I,
yeah,
I liked the Ford did that.
I was like,
good for you.
You're like,
you're making enough cool shit that people want to buy it.
Yeah.
It's a fun ass fucking car.
But the whole convertible thing,
you start thinking,
hmm,
shouldn't ever do something like this is kind of Dell.
I would feel better.
The biggest problem with the Shelby brand is that is that their customers don't,
you know,
it's a great like five tenths car cruise around in it and you make some noise,
you do a poll here and there.
It's all about you know,
track and you're like,
hmm,
I don't know about this.
Yeah.
What it is is a muscle car.
It's a fun muscle car where you can choose to break the wheels loose a little
bit.
You could choose to have a little fun.
It's got an amazing sound to,
it just sounds incredible.
It's just have a stock exhaust,
the stock exhaust.
It's fucking great tune those things.
Yeah,
they designed them.
They are optimum sound.
I've been to a proving
grounds out of Romeo for,
they come out with that car.
They have a guy and,
and you know one of the best jobs.
Like you take my job,
which is a good job.
And then there's,
you know,
pre production tester.
Right.
Which sounds like a dope job.
This fucking one pour SAP is out at the Romeo proving grounds and has to do 500
consecutive full boards.
Rag launches on the clutch.
This guy,
all he does like four days over,
it'll drag on.
They can't get a machine to do that.
That seems ridiculous.
That's pretty bad ass though.
I mean he literally drives the same 50 feet of go over and
do not want to fuck with that guy in a red light con.
Oh my God.
That guy knows that he wouldn't be a professional.
His launch skills,
most people just ruthless nasty.
He sets the fucking time man alone though.
Nobody knows.
It's like a tree falling in the woods.
Nobody's there to hear him.
He raised with people.
People roll up to you.
They don't do it.
It's stupid.
I want to do that.
Do you,
do you worry that things like this that you're talking about like the visceral
experience of driving a car or being missed by a lot of people and that like the
manual transmission will die off?
I'm really happy that like that the Camaro still have it.
The Mustang still have with the corvette.
Still have the Viber still hasn't,
but I'm really sad when he see,
uh,
going to get into like a Porsche and their only button as a drive button and you
got like,
oh,
okay,
I can,
I can either shift with this or I can shift with these things and just press one
foot,
just one foot.
Hmm.
Okay.
Well then I'm not as involved.
I would like to be involved.
Good at the,
at the teacher.
You do all of it or let me do well,
did this shifting thing.
The problem with taking it out of the mix is I don't need it to go that fast.
Right?
Like it's already going fast.
Like it doesn't need to go one 100th of a second faster because you can shift
the gears for me.
I would like to do that.
Please write tube,
dude.
Yeah.
This one went around the Nurburgring four seconds faster than the other one,
right.
You know that.
But is it a big marketing thing?
You,
when I say who cares because we're fucking normal man.
The people that's a combo.
These fucking cars do they,
they can't fucking drive.
Right.
It's true.
Some of them can't.
And some of them you certainly can't.
And you know the other,
the other issue is it's what is what is really fun.
And with a lot of these cars it's not nearly as fun and you have to drive faster
to make it more fun cause there's not that visceral connection to the driver
experience.
Sure.
Like your Prius.
I like having that mechanical connection.
The clutch pedal makes a difference.
It's a fun experience.
And I think,
like we said earlier,
we,
you liken it to a ride cause that's really what it's like.
You know what I mean?
And then when you're seeing a guy like Chris Harris has going around a corner,
to me that's not much different than a skateboard.
That does awesome tricks.
You know what I'm seeing some dude's just letting it hang out there.
Who's awesome.
She's awesome at it.
And he's like Tanner files,
driver showers,
you know,
people
talk,
you know,
all day it's like,
oh you fucking suck.
Compared to Chris Harris.
I'm sorry if I'm not insane.
And in a foreign country,
like what do you mean?
That's not your thing?
I mean,
your thing is,
I'm a regular guy and here's what it's like to drive these ridiculous,
I pull the kid in the candy store.
You know when you're British,
then you're expected to drive sports cars and be the most l and steal our women.
Well,
you're much smarter.
You know,
you're clearly more,
more likely to be a representative of a company.
30 Iq points.
Yeah.
You would be a better commercial spokesperson for a bank.
Really have a British accent hotter if you're a chick.
Yeah.
There's something extra there or a dude.
Every time I go on my British friends,
I'm like,
you fucks her all cheating.
This is,
you're not smart.
You don't have anything to offer,
but Eto nef and that's it.
Hold on.
It's right away.
Everybody's excited about them.
It's different what his parents were in colony.
He pulls the hose like crazy.
It's unbelievable being something different than their parents or something
exotic,
something serious.
They're the farthest she could break away from our desk.
Fuck you.
That's it.
Other than a black guy,
you're the little,
the second less dangerous.
You're like right next door if you have a British [inaudible].
Have you ever gotten,
if you've ever had gotten laid because of a car?
No.
Me Either.
All I get asked every day,
what car do I use to get chicks?
I'm like,
you better change your fucking angle,
homie.
Yeah.
You've met a develop your life son.
My car's getting me like unwanted teenage boy attention.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
Well the cars that we like or like I pulled up,
I saw your corvette,
you have this custom core,
but it looks like it's a early two thousands maybe in [inaudible] 98.
Wow.
It's,
it's done.
I've racing seats and you know,
fat tires on it.
And he changed the headlights so they don't pop up anymore.
And I like,
for me,
I look at sometime ago UE,
Debbie furniture,
you should try it.
You like it?
It's 2,900 pounds.
It's 500 horsepower coil overs and 14 inch brakes.
Very sticky tires.
Must be ridiculous.
It's so fun.
But to a check,
they'd be like,
what is this?
Uh,
I you want me to get in that car?
I picked up a chick once in that car at a bar and we went out.
We went into the bar and was the sound of the badly no.
Then it ends,
well actually she gets in the car and I assume you've been in a corvette at
least once in your life.
Well it says corvette across the dashboard right across the passenger
compartment.
She gets in the car,
looks around.
I'm like putting the harnesses on her cause it's got five point harnesses and
she goes,
oh my God.
Like I can't believe you drive a Ferrari.
And I,
and I'm just like yeah man.
You know the maintenance is really a pitch.
Is that a good sign though for the rest of the night?
Yeah,
I convert.
If you wanted to make a really stupid kid,
I was able to convert that one.
Yeah.
Cause intelligence comes from the mom.
Thankfully.
Does it,
do they know that for sure?
I don't know.
That's probably one of them.
How did they try to pretend that we did that and we should pursue that on
questions?
Everything.
I don't think that's an old watch.
Straight Shit.
Intelligence varies inside the family.
I mean,
how can you mean?
Who the hell knows who's getting the good dose of what it's all chance until
they dial that shit in?
Yeah,
intelligent varies inside of a family.
We've all seen the dude's whose brother is like wicked smart and your friends
dumb.
You're like,
what the fuck man?
Why is your brother so smart?
We got for you and you're just stupid as shit.
I know people who've got their APP for sure.
Add Valerie's,
man,
I hope I didn't get the crap.
I don't know how many,
how many brothers and sisters?
The key to life is,
don't worry about it.
Actually my sister's like me,
but for cosmetics,
cosmetics,
a guru of like cosmetics,
Alexis and daily glow.com there we go.
That's daily glow.com it's my sisters.
We do get girls that listen to this and they would want to support.
It's nice to,
it's nice to throw a tossed your system.
What percent of [inaudible] wrong with that?
Along with that,
I'm admiring that.
That's what percentage female listeners that you really,
probably a less than one.
Yeah,
I know this girl,
angry lesbians,
the ones that I have,
they're all lesbians.
It'll punch you.
Are they looking to hate you?
No,
I'm just kidding.
We get,
there's a lot of,
my ex does derby.
The Ian's probably nowhere.
There's a lot.
I think for some,
some girls they,
they love hearing what guys really think.
Yeah,
but not even masochistic.
I'm not sadistic or masochistic.
Unfiltered.
Yeah.
Well,
it's also being a male and honest male as opposed to this weird situation where
a lot of us find ourselves in where we have to work,
corporate jobs where we were really forced to behave it completely different
way.
Contrary to nature for eight hours a day.
And Alan Alda,
it's not your fault in life that that kind of life can beat you.
And so how do you hear people talking?
Shit take,
what do you turn into corporate Joe Rogan?
Well,
if you have to,
what does that even mean?
I don't even know what that means.
Well,
because when you do your fucking live reads and shit,
it seems like you're intentionally rolling your eyes.
No,
no.
With this on this.
Oh,
with that stuff because that's all know,
those are not corporate.
But those are to me is shit that I would use and companies that are nice and
they don't give me a hard time about the way I do the commercials all fucked up.
So what's the fear factor?
That was probably the most corporate thing that I ever had to do.
I guess you would call that corporate,
but you know,
it was,
it was without a doubt the most centered mainstream.
Well,
did you try,
did you try and,
you know,
get either not sneaking material,
but it was their interaction,
a lot of interactions that happen on fear factor that got hacked out later
because of course there's so much time it,
that's the thing we're running into with this questions.
Everything showed too,
is there so much time that gets chopped down to 44 minutes?
That's what it is with commercials.
And there was a lot of cool moments,
you know,
fear factor like that.
Uh,
I'm sure it got left in the editing floor to like,
you know,
people,
uh,
getting through things.
We couldn't show the whole thing.
You know,
there's a,
that this was a stupid show and a lot of ways,
but there was some like really to this day,
some crazy inspirational moments.
This is one show with his mother and daughter team beat this Douchey Dad and son
team and the dad and son team were sound like,
I shouldn't say douchey.
They were just being men,
you know,
and they were being men who are competing and they were,
they get their little cunty,
which is what people do when they're,
you know,
trying to win a competition.
They tend to talk shit at her special cameras everywhere,
especially men.
Men,
men are terrible.
Gotcha.
And so these guys,
everybody assumed because it was a very physical stunt,
everybody assumed that the father and son,
we're going to win because they had a physical advantage,
but they fucked up and they,
when they fucked up,
they fucked up hard.
Like it was a big fuck up and the Sun fucked up and the dad fucked up.
They both fucked up.
It was a big deal.
Wow.
And then this chick and her daughter,
they,
they won and started crying and the whole,
like the,
the
can't remember crying.
I was crying.
Is there,
and there's this fear factor.
No,
no.
There's the people that were working in a straight up,
no,
it wasn't an in studio was vocations dock near the ocean.
That's pure.
Yeah.
I think the camera and were crying.
The producers are crying.
It's a real reaction.
That's not stupid.
Healing hands.
Yeah.
So I,
it was a lot of stupid shit,
but I saw stuff like that too.
But you know that that show was honest.
It wasn't pretending to be anything.
It wasn't so like I love that show because it was like,
hey,
you're going to do some crazy shit.
You might eat some crazy shit and we're all having fun and somebody's going to
win some money.
You know,
the people that worked on that show with the nicest fucking humans that have
ever lived there was so nice.
Like the p the behind the scenes people.
Everybody's so nice.
I was like,
that's yours.
It wasn't fake.
I had a,
I had a fucking shit experience on TV last time and it was because it was,
the fake is fucking shit and you can have no
speed as a whole.
I don't even,
I don't.
I'll probably get,
I'll probably never get hard again.
No.
How about I love Dan Neil and I love John Sally.
Did you ever read Dan Neil?
Is that he was in the,
he was an automotive writer for the La Times and now with the Wall Street
Journal,
first guy to win a Pulitzer.
He's wrote about cars.
Hilarious.
A genius writer.
Hilarious,
weird guy.
He left La to go to the Wall Street Journal and he's super,
he's from North Carolina,
but put them on to light for the first time,
you know,
high society type kind of these tickets.
Wired Science.
I did a show for PBS,
a pilot,
wired magazine,
a weekly.
It was designed to be a weekly 60 minutes of science.
It was,
you know,
one of those great disappointment that it didn't work words but you'd never was.
That's the huge fucking words.
He's a smart motherfucker and he was hilarious,
but I didn't use him for cars.
We dove this underwater habitat that the national oceanographic and Atmospheric
Administration has 60 feet beneath the surface of the ocean off of key Largo.
It was so cool.
He's every time I astronauts train them on our podcast cause he always comes up
with fucking gold.
He's just in one or two beverages.
He is the fucking greatest.
So you would like him.
He was hilarious and John and Sally who was the greatest.
It's a lot of characters in the world of journalism,
that's for sure.
One of the cool things about car journalism today is that you're getting these
characters that a leak over in a car journalism as well.
I don't think they were there for a long time.
Right.
I fell into it like I,
people ask me everyday how I got my job.
It's,
it was the craziest series of accidents.
It was like when I was a kid,
I always knew I wanted to do something with cars.
I was obsessed with it and then like,
but I was like,
nobody makes any money doing that shit.
So you know,
and uh,
I tried to become a photographer,
didn't work out,
try to do graphic design,
didn't work out.
And then it was like I found the job opening at an exotic car rental company and
I left that and opened the car wash like anything I could do to be around cars.
And I started a driving club and I was like,
I thought it was an added bonus to our members.
We should probably make videos of the drives we went on.
They would love,
these are ego people.
So I hired this kid at a college who was like crazy cause he would hang out on
my vet at like 150 miles an hour.
So we hired him,
we start making these videos.
After the third or fourth video,
the guy came when he came home with a microphone,
like a news anchor microphone is like here,
host the video.
And I hosted the video.
Not One week later a guy called me and goes,
do you want a job?
And,
and it was like,
it was a matter of he brought the microphone home.
My Dad and I was a car journalist.
The next fucking week was that a meal.
So when people ask me all the time like,
how do I get your job?
Like the answer is just like be me.
And then I don't know what the fuck else to tell you.
Just sort of the doors just opened.
The flood gate opened immediately and out of nowhere.
And it was a cool,
weird
man.
It's a cool gay because like there's always gonna be someone who like car guys
love to watch videos on cars.
You know,
I like even cars I know I'm never going to buy right now.
Don't even considering,
you know,
I,
I love,
I love just watching.
You're just curious.
I love,
I love the designs of them.
I loved the,
the whole idea of the changing of the engines and the lower this and move that
and move the engine forward and move.
You know,
I loved the improvements on things.
I think fascinated by it.
When make films,
it's not just about the car.
I mean all of them.
Everyone on my crew and like I wouldn't be anywhere without the very five Tom
Zak Fed Nino,
you know fucking yeah,
I wouldn't be anywhere without those people who actually make the films look
pretty and everyone has a background in photography or video.
You can tell it's all really well shot and we take,
we really take pride in that and like even though it's like dumb youtube videos,
like we shoot with like $100,000 worth of camera gear can youtube video,
there's no dumb youtube videos.
Once they get into the thousands and thousands of views,
you start once it essentially it's just a show that is distributed in a
different way.
Yeah,
we make it like TV,
which I think the distinction is kind of silly at this point because the merging
of technology,
the merging of television and the Internet is so inevitable that a show's a show
and if you pull it off on the internet,
it's really cool.
Good for you.
If you pull it off on TV and it's really cool.
It's just a show.
But the Internet still enough of the wild west that we're having.
You know what I mean?
I don't have to answer some fucking a suit.
That's why it's good.
Who thinks he knows more than me about how to make a car video.
Fucking pisses me off.
It should ever want to listen to anyone tell me how to make a car video.
Fuck you.
Shit you off.
You know why?
Because you're an interesting guy and nobody knows how to tell you to be you.
You're a fun guy and in people want to hear you talk about a car.
Like it's a fun thing to see you running through the gear like that,
that video,
that Porsche video,
that Bvi Porsche video.
Watch that at least four times.
Terrific.
I may take 12 cents off that thing
just on Joe.
This BBI cat.
What's his name?
What's his Joe.
Joey.
Joey Seely,
one of the Co owners of Bbi auto sport.
I'm just going to keep doing it.
Yeah,
go ahead.
Takes this.
Um,
1985 Porsche and he turns it into this insane car.
He cuts out everything.
There's no floor board when there's no um,
uh,
mats.
Floormates,
no ins sound installation,
no carpet.
It's got like stripped.
Yeah.
This like little aluminum shifter.
It's like he's no radio,
no air conditioning.
40,000 miles on it.
Wow.
Chassis.
That crazy.
It's amazing.
And it's rock that the galvanize Porsche bodies from the eighties and nineties,
like,
like good medic.
Todd's Porsche.
It's going to last forever.
Wow.
You know,
I believe it and you have to let me take you down there.
I gotta I gotta take you down there and you've got to drive a couple of their
cars cause they build the craziest shit.
Yeah,
I've seen a couple of your videos on it.
The one with the a nine,
911 turbo s 10,
Oh quarter mile.
They took a nine,
911 turbo s and they were like not fast enough.
Let's,
let's,
let's Jack it up to more than 600 horsepower.
So that guy who has that nine,
nine,
seven,
is this the,
oh,
there's the video right there.
So this guy,
the guy who owns this car,
his name is Eric,
and his gray car is terrifying.
She has about 40,000 miles on this car.
It says daily driver and it's dual clutch,
right?
That,
so it's got launched control.
He launches this car every single day.
Sweet shot.
Every single day.
He's on
the car.
He launches the fucking car.
I launched it 10 times in a row.
Wow.
No problems.
PDK is the nastiest dual clutch transmission.
You can beat the fucking hell out of the car.
They'll take it.
Yeah.
Do you remember when the Nissan gtrs first came out and everybody was launched
controlling them?
When they're blowing,
you would,
you would hear like,
well,
if you did it once,
you'll avoid you void your warranty.
Well,
why is it there?
Yeah,
you advertise this shit.
I put it on the car.
How many times where you're allowed to do it?
Well,
none.
None.
No,
none.
No.
Forget,
forget.
Not even use the logic.
You,
if you put it in launch control mode and never launched it,
you're done.
That is so funny that it's so funny.
You violate your warranty.
I very strongly voided someone's warranty doing that.
Actually,
I personally avoided someone's on purpose.
Yeah,
we,
we took a Nissan Gtr to the drag strip and we rented one of those a Z,
h z Corvettes from hertz yellow and black ones and we put a fucking 200 shot dry
fog on it.
We sprayed the rental car.
I remember I watched that Truss,
the carbon on nitrogen.
I don't know what the fuck he just said.
We've got a rental type of stimulant to an automobile.
How would you describe it and yeah,
if people don't know what nitric makes the air that goes into the car very,
very cold and if it runs cold it means it makes more power.
So you can make a bunch more power basically by hitting a button and spraying
this gas,
which makes your,
makes you conscious for your engine speed.
Dust.
Yes and no.
Yes.
I mean no,
no.
Until it is,
you know what I mean?
You know,
that's a great way to,
you know what I mean?
Like is it dangerous to have sex with someone with AIDS?
No,
until it is.
Wow.
I would say yes every time.
I don't know how you give advice.
I'm a little bit more,
I live dangerous.
Cigarette circumspect.
Yeah,
little ones.
The video got a million views.
I got a band.
Right.
Hurts for life or for doing that.
Wow.
They're mad at you.
Well,
what about Eva Davis?
Give a fuck.
Fortunately we've got enterprise,
there's a lot of car rental companies.
You can work your way through.
Yeah,
they must be like,
hey dickhead.
That's not what we rented it for.
Enterprises.
Minis in every car.
Rental counter in America.
Now when you read this guy a car,
no matter what,
don't rent them a car.
So downtime.
So you want to character when they do.
When?
When you go there,
like if you went there,
they would literally tell you you can't rent a car from them.
I think so.
I mean I got a letter from the vice president of the company saying I was band.
Do you try to see you?
Yes.
How much do they want?
They wanted me to buy the car coordinates.
That seems reasonable.
What was funny was how much they wanted for the car.
How much was it?
The car was like a year and a half fold.
It's a corvette.
It was a year and a half old and it had like 10,000 miles on it and they wanted
to make me buy it for $16,000 which is unbelievably
low.
And then I realized why salvage title,
they rented me a car that was on a salvage title.
It already had already been totaled and brought back and they tried to sue me
into buying it.
Oh my God.
I thought about partying it out.
Actually I thought about right there.
Isn't that crazy that they rented you a car that was salvaged and legal?
It's legal to do.
Well they can.
They fix things 100% now having driven that car,
I could tell you it was not 100%
I can tell you that car,
that car.
Do you in a past life?
I don't know.
I can only tell you what it did in mine as a storm trooper.
Probably Nazi Germany could be brought into this life and get abused.
Like it was a panzer tank hit in an accident and it was a,
it was a 2009.
Oh,
there's the video.
Look,
there's the corvette.
Is it 2009 models?
Hello everybody at Hertz.
I hope you're paying attention to this.
[inaudible] it's too late.
So,
um,
those cars,
like they seem a little plasticky to begin with because they're made of plastic.
When they take a big hit like the can,
they just bend everything back into position and they kind of explode like
shattery shattered.
So they replace all the stuff that shattered off.
Yeah.
Is it like less impact resistant than a regular car?
I mean,
there were only known for being kind of dangerous.
They're not known like,
like not a pinto,
like less people dying them than you think this video is hilarious to.
That's it.
That's really reassuring.
No car.
He took a fucking rental car from Hertz and you put a blower in it?
No nitrate actress in it.
Yeah.
What is it called?
What do you call it?
What did you call it?
Spray and that's it.
He's spraying it.
Macular,
I'm sorry,
I fucked up with blower.
I meant to say spray,
but the ID of that of just shoving that shit and some phonies.
Fucking rental car.
A friend of mine [inaudible].
I love that.
A friend of mine,
that interest kit that goes into Smith's in a suitcase.
Bergen is a carry on.
Carry on.
No,
no,
but you can make it into a rental car.
Supposedly.
Really got us,
I don't know.
I wouldn't like assemble and he would sneak it in and then a parking lot.
I mean allegedly if you were some,
somebody doesn't even exist.
Guy I heard about.
I don't mind and just slapped that bitch on.
Theoretically.
Yeah.
How long would it take you to do that?
10 minutes.
It's just hoses.
It's only 10 minutes.
You could have nitrous.
There is a guy who was well known who would fly around the country and rent a
Ford Taurus at every place.
He any weekend he would bracket drag race because he knew that valley that that
Ford Taurus would run a 16 one every time,
no matter the condition.
And he could just fly anywhere,
show up with a rented car and run the same fucking number.
Every time it went down a bunch of mouse.
Was He laying down a bunch of pets and you would make a living off it?
Cause it's bracket.
So it's price is right.
Rules drag racing.
Wow.
That's hilarious.
Drag racing to me.
I never give a fuck about it now.
It seemed to me like,
yeah,
I get it.
You got there quicker.
Whatever you'd like,
you can try standing mile.
It's fun.
Well I what?
I'm sure it is fun,
but what I really enjoy watching his people maneuver for position when people
were on a track and you know,
and it's a real regular one,
Dan.
That's where it's really exciting.
And I know that's also,
words were like fucking Super Dangerous Trillion v eight supercar you ever watch
any of that shit?
No.
What does that good stuff?
Because they're driving cars that look like road cars.
Right.
Dot.
Neath they're more like Nascar's,
but they looked like road cars and it's,
you know,
Nascar levels of rubbing and bumping,
but on road courses with left and right turns.
That's amazing.
It's nasty stuff.
It's really good.
Right?
Where do they do that?
I mean in Australia a lot,
but they also have overall here they did a circuit of the Americas race I think.
And they did like a Sonoma race or something.
Um,
they tore,
but it's,
it's bad ass racing.
It's good stuff.
Wow.
You know what you should do?
I never,
I'm doing this.
I get wary whenever someone says,
you know what you should do,
you know,
get me hooked on this new Jang.
We'll know how much money have you spent?
There's V eight supercar.
How much money have you spent in your Porsche?
A Lot,
right?
It costs a few bucks.
Right?
So don't you want to drive it fast?
Yeah.
Okay.
So September 13th to 15th what is it?
Silver state classic in Nevada.
Okay.
They shut down 91 miles of highway right now.
I never have the time to spend three days somewhere driving your car.
You only,
it's only one day.
The race,
big races.
Only one day we could do it for one day.
It's a classic race.
It's a straight line road race students and 91 miles of highway shutdown.
And you want to average 150 miles an hour over night.
You know,
it seems like,
it seems like it'd be a recipe for driving really fast at a bunch of people who
don't know that well.
No,
no,
no.
It's not a wheel to wheel race.
You go off like two minutes at a time.
You're okay.
You're at a time when you would've fucking road and you're 500 horsepower
Porsche.
So I'm just driving straight.
Well it's like eight miles straight and then a turn and then 10 miles straight
and then it turned and then you know,
but it's 91 miles.
So you,
you go 91 miles and like 25 minutes I believe.
Yeah.
It's like New York to Philly in 25 minutes.
Crazy.
Here's the Santa Barbara.
It sounds very dangerous.
Yeah.
And Fun.
You fight people?
I don't anymore.
I barely grapple.
You did fight people.
Yeah.
Only the one only in tournaments and the real world.
Much more likely to get out of the way.
Just be friendly.
Right.
Well,
the same thrill seekers that would love to drive a car like really fast would
also like to do MMA or motorcross ride or don't want to fight anybody.
Low driving cars.
You were just
have a different thing.
You know?
It's a different expression of the thrill Jean.
I know.
I don't know if it's a real thing,
but there's a thing that men,
I'll have that there's a certain amount of stimulation we seem to have to have
in our lives for whatever reason.
Yeah.
For whatever reason,
I don't know what the fuck that is.
Well,
adrenaline's fun driving once again,
fucking drug man.
It is a great one.
As long as it doesn't get away from you,
you want to feel alive.
I mean that's why driving fast as such a kick because it's fascinating when you
watch adrenaline lock someone up to do.
Then when you see someone get like completely locked up with adrenaline,
one of the more fascinating things about fighting is watched people walk to the
cage and seeing them managing that anticipation there.
I's like moving around like what's going on in their head and she,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean different ways of dealing with it.
Everybody has a sort of a different approach,
but everyone is experiencing extreme,
a level of adrenaline that adrenaline.
The experience must be just unbearable.
I've never done anything as intense as fighting in an MMA bout,
but the things that I've done,
it scared the shit out of me and I know that that's even scarier and not some
adrenaline shit.
I manage it by talking a lot.
Some people manage it with like silence,
you know what I mean?
Some people managing with like fucking moving around.
Whenever I manage it by taught huge surprise.
I manage it by talking a lot,
but fucking well,
whatever calms you down,
right?
That's the idea.
Whatever keeps you relaxed.
That's just what's the scariest thing you've done?
Martial arts competitions for sure.
Yeah.
Stand up second,
but only in the beginning.
Only in the beginning when,
when I first did it or the moments that have bombed.
I've had,
I've had some horrific fucking death defying bottom of the stand up on terrified
of it.
Man Bombing.
I steal a joke for myself.
It's like sucking a thousand Dick's in front of your mother.
It's the most embarrassed a man could ever be in life and I've done it many
times.
That's horrible.
Yeah,
you'll learn and grow from it.
But yeah,
you take a fun hobby.
Terrified of it,
man.
I,
when we,
when I was doing the speed show,
they had,
would have a comic for inbetween fucking takes like the crowd,
right guy,
whatever.
I'm up guide and every once in a while I'd grabbed the mic from him and like
relieve him because I figured like I'm on the show,
I get at least hold their attention for five fucking minutes and I would tell
him to.
Then I got some decent laughs,
but I felt like,
I felt like that audience was like,
you know,
I'm scared to go to a random audience and do it well.
You would just need a different introduction.
They would need to let them know what you're about.
And then you could do that through a for a couple of jokes and then they get
used to whoever you are and then they sort of either accept you or don't.
It's definitely easier if they know who you are,
like they know who you are from a show,
from your show,
they're already fans.
Then it's easy.
They know your sense of humor cause you express it a lot and a lot of your
videos,
it will be an easy transition.
Like you could probably do,
you have a lot of hits on those videos.
You know,
you could probably do stand up in a place if you wanted to try it.
if you wanted to,
you should go to like an open mic night and then try like a night somewhere,
have a bunch of professional comedians and then you go up and do like 10
minutes.
Like Sandwich yourself in with other people that are pros.
That's scary shit to me.
Go to an open mic night throws sounds really scary to me.
You know the good thing about open Mike nights in everyone's socks.
Yeah,
that's it.
I think it was Richard Jenny's that said that the good thing about bad comedians
is it inspires people to try it and I think he's right.
He was.
He was totally right because that's funny.
When you go to an open mic night,
you go,
oh,
okay.
It's not like everybody's a Richard Pryor here.
Right.
This is okay.
This,
yeah.
This is obviously be all right.
I'll be all right.
I mean very difficult to do really bad comedy and being like,
well,
I can fucking do better than that guy,
man.
Yeah,
we all have.
Yeah.
There's no doubt about that.
I'm sure you have,
but I just,
I feel like there's something,
there's something different from being funny around people you know,
and being funny around strangers is a really big difference.
Yeah,
it's a big difference for sure.
I'm not sure what it takes to pull it off if I'm actually funny.
Yeah,
you could do that.
It can be funny.
You could do it.
It just takes focus.
You would just have to decide that that's who you are.
You're extending comedian,
then you start riding and working at it and yeah,
you could do it.
You could totally do it.
You'd probably enjoy it.
It's probably perfect for your personality.
I'm a decent storyteller.
I think you tell decent stories on the show.
These are stories.
I have the time.
Listen,
man,
you could totally do it.
It's,
it's one of those things where it's not magic.
You know?
It's not like either have to be seven foot tall.
He can't play basketball.
No,
it's not that.
It's this.
If you have,
uh,
an ability to communicate and you have something to say,
you can figure it out.
In fact,
uh,
a certain amount of self loving doesn't actually help.
Helps a little.
A little helps learn that from Jim Norton.
Nothing wrong with that or not having it.
That's okay too.
It's whoever the fuck you really are.
Yeah.
I do sell flow,
self-loving.
Nothing wrong with that.
You know,
one of the shows are going to hate myself.
Dude,
why are you now?
Why now?
I'm not in that business.
You don't need a shrink me.
It's okay.
It's all,
it's a problem.
I've always had it fucking well.
It comes with the growing up being the fact that it happens,
right?
What are you gonna do?
Yeah,
but you're a different person now and you guys have,
cause I learned,
I learned that from him.
I learned,
you guys get to make out.
I'm going to pay the room is full of love and I learned from Jim Norton,
Opie and Anthony that you can be,
you're going gonna walk away from the love Joe.
Nothing wrong.
We can embrace the filth that I've embraced the film and the depth.
We were talking about that I guess before the podcast itself,
we're talking about opie and Anthony being one of the reasons why you got into
it,
that you saw them and you were like,
Holy Shit.
Like I actually,
I think I could do something.
I used to be so insecure.
Do you know?
I can't.
You wouldn't even believe because I pass off as an extrovert now,
even though I'm really insecure.
I was about the properly insecure back in the day until I discovered that you
can actually say like disgusting things and not old and have people laugh and
make a living off it.
That was amazing.
Yeah.
And it was like all Norton Opie and Anthony and Patrice who I got to meet before
he died.
Fucking thank God.
I think a lot of people that are involved in the entertainment business or uh,
at least initially insecure that you kind have to be,
to want that much tension to put yourself up in front of that many people,
the you'll,
you get to a position like that only if you have a deficit in my opinion.
But there's a difference between an off,
that's all it's doing it and being,
you know,
in some actors who need,
who needed the attention.
Right.
Yeah.
Well Guy Knew Anna Paquin when we were like 18,
19.
Wow.
That was interesting.
My Friend Day at school and not sure mushrooms for the first time ever.
I'm not sure who that was.
Untrue blood.
Oh,
okay.
I never watched won an Oscar at 12 actress.
So this really amazing,
when we were 19,
I gave her mushrooms for the first time.
It allegedly pretending she was fibbing.
You heard of lol?
Worry about how well I sort of statute of limitations the nation.
I don't think so.
Not In this day and age.
The NDA.
See Wpp,
the um,
I think in this day and age,
this is one of the,
uh,
I think this is one of the weirdest times to,
to grow up and uh,
to know that mushrooms are still illegal.
If you're illegal,
if you're listening to this,
if you're in high school or if you're in college and you know,
you,
you find out about what's legal and what's illegal and how it got there,
there's a,
that's the bullshit tipping point.
That's the tipping point where you realize where you look at things and you go,
wait a minute,
what are they doing?
This makes no sense.
Hold on.
What?
Schedule One and you find out scheduled one is marijuana.
Marijuana has no medicinal value.
And then you'd like just see all these people that have emphysema or glaucoma or
what aids,
whatever the fuck they have.
I have,
I've had two back surgeries.
Cancer's me straight up.
It helps people.
It helps people relax.
But then you see this shit that scheduled too.
It's scheduled to his cocaine.
Heroin,
heroin and cocaine have medicinal value,
which is when did they have medicinal value in like 1905.
No,
they still in opiates like for pills for oxycontin.
That's when they figured out it was good and I'm Methadone in the,
in the right circumstances.
Those are really helpful.
Yeah.
Medical cocaine is a real thing that you really do use that photo stream.
They use it for something.
I know line of Cain is like the gay cousin of cocaine.
That's a type of uh,
it's like cocaine.
She's different.
It's just different guys thing.
What happens when they married?
Um,
they,
they just,
they married inside your nose when you do surgery on it.
That's a lot of canes for,
they numb you.
What?
It's a weird,
nasty tasting thing that makes your heart feel funny.
Yeah.
They did it to me when I have my nose fixed.
I had a deviated septum that one of the,
if you folks,
if you please listen to me,
if you have it and you know guy who could fix it and he's a good doctor and he's
good at it,
please get it fixed.
It will change your fucking life.
Change your life.
I was a mouth breather most of my life.
I was like,
cause you'd been hit too many.
Well I fell down a flight of stairs when I was five,
before even before the hitting,
I broke my nose.
I was an idiot.
I was walking into trees and shit.
So then martial arts for a long time,
in the beginning I wasn't good,
so I
got hit a lot,
you know?
So I'm sure my nose took a beating people,
the city of surgery,
dude,
I've been scared to get the surgery.
Every memory time I've had to get a surgery.
I've been like putting it off,
putting it off,
putting off,
putting off and just being in pain.
This has been my spine.
And,
and then I get the surgery and I wake up a fucking hour later and I'm like,
oh,
why didn't I get the surgery?
Like fucking surgeries.
Have you had done your back?
I did the Baja 1000 race in 2003.
That's that crazy race down in men's Mexico.
It's off road and I burst the l four l five disc.
Could you guys spot rash?
No,
just from compression.
Not Know Chris from jumping up and down your 30 hours.
There's ditches like this
800 over stuff.
They call them.
Whoops.
List race.
My friend bud,
Bud Brotzmann who is the executive producer of rides.
He does that shit every year.
That motherfucker every year.
I mean I didn't crash and I and I burst the disc in my spine.
Have those special Ford trucks the craziest for your honors.
Jesus floods.
Shit.
It's 35 inch travel on the shocks on my 35 inch travel.
Like that's almost three feet.
So when it's done,
okay,
you're,
you're disbursed.
What do they do?
The fuse it?
Uh,
no I have with the,
I had a Mike Rowe diskectomy so they fixed it without having to fuse it.
Then I did the same thing again.
Like same years later.
I didn't do Baja.
I drove cross country in a Camaro that did it.
What year?
2010 that's when the Camaro had such a bad seating position for me that sitting
in cars cause all right so I'm going to,
this is going to be tough.
You,
oh you're on camera cause you're tall.
So the roof was too short.
They have a weird roof too far.
I had to lean too far back and then reach forward.
Meaning my spine was like a c so every time I hit a bump that c would just
compress so at it again and I had to have it fixed again.
How so?
When they're fixing it,
they're just chucking a little piece of it off basically.
Yeah.
But after that you feel only get two,
you only get two.
I've had the to the next step is fusion and that's bad.
No more Baja for you while unfortunate care of yourself?
I try to,
but my job,
I stretch a lot.
I go to physical therapy,
I ride my bike when I'm home,
but unfortunately doing my job makes it worse.
Not doing my job makes it better.
Oh,
I see.
So driving the cars,
driving cars is what does it,
do you ask what your size your back?
I do when I'm home,
but I'm,
I'm a,
I'm home seven days.
The month of August I'm doing a 500 mile off road trip and the 2000 miles across
Europe in the same month with a bad spine man.
It's rough.
Yeah.
You know what man,
if you can make it a priority every place you stopped to go to a gym,
it would help me tremendously.
I'm sure it was strengthening your back will go a long to protecting
you in that situation.
I think
last summer I had like a lull in work for a couple months and I didn't work very
much and if the traveler much and I got,
I lost like 60 pounds.
I was just fucking great shape and then it just,
I started working again.
It's like the more money I make,
the worst physically I get.
And then I go,
you know,
if I'm broke,
I'm in great shape.
Moma fat.
You know,
it's,
and it sounds like I'm making excuses because I partially am,
because if I really,
I feel like if I really was committed that much,
I'd find a gym at the Holiday Inn,
you know?
But it's,
but as much as I love my job,
the days are long as fuck man.
You know,
my life sounds super glamorous when it's hacked down to 10 minutes a week,
you know,
the other,
how many days a week do you film car videos?
I'm filming one or two days a week,
but it's the other shit,
you know,
there's,
there's seven,
800 mile transits that we're driving rather than trying to save money and stays
in front of my computer fucking,
you know,
sourcing shit out and it's a fits fulltime.
Do you hunt down all these various places that you go to yourself?
Wow.
So it's just basically through your connections in the car world.
And I do our social media.
I do all our youtube management.
I do all that stuff.
How listen,
it must be a massive blessing to people like BBI.
Like you,
you blew them up,
man.
You know that video put look,
a lot of people like I'm sure called that place and said,
I want one of those fucking things.
We have estimated that appearing on our show for a shop is about $50,000 worth
of marketing value.
I think that's probably being the lowest and being conservative because those
videos are going to be around for a long ass time and you're dealing with,
as we were talking about really clock cars that are never going to go out of
style in 1980s Porsche or 1970s Porsche.
You're always going to want one of those,
so if you find some guy who builds the most wicked 1980s Porsche,
but you don't find out about it until 2024 and people were still driving cars,
you're still going to want to see that.
Yeah,
that stuff over the,
over the longterm,
I think will work.
That's going to be so weird when everybody else is fucking flying hovercrafts
and shit.
We're still like,
oh,
I hope they save us the cars,
man.
You know,
if the same me,
then that saved me the fucking premium octane,
I'll use it.
There will always be gas.
I'm all about limiting around in my volt to fucking use my corvette on the
weekends.
Why wouldn't makes you so confident that there will always be gasoline?
Because internal combustion engines are easy.
They're easy to fix,
they're easy to run,
and they're a relatively efficient in terms of,
you know,
the amount of power out.
The power density is a bunch of people they believe in,
in,
in the fact that the oil's running out,
right.
Peak oil,
it's called you don't subscribe to that is it really?
The science is not good.
They keep finding more oil and there there've been some studies done where on a
seabed oil just sort of appeared spontaneously.
There's
new oil being made all the long term.
I think they're probably right in the long,
long term,
but I really,
I think we're going to find something when it comes down to it,
when it really fucking comes down to it,
people get shit done.
We're going to be using it now before we run.
I haven't driven a hydrogen car before.
It drives like a fucking car.
Is that the Honda?
Did you drive a Honda,
the Honda or the BMW?
Yeah,
they drive like cars,
oil,
oil coming off the seabed floor.
That's a new thing that I just discovered recently to or heard of it heard
about.
I found some oil on the ground.
I was like,
wow,
this is weird.
And uh,
we googled it and it turns out like a lot of it is just natural.
Just comes out of the uh,
the bottom of the ocean out here near Malibu.
It was really,
I mean I guess they drill it loss go like they've got one at offshore oil
platforms and who knows what's happening there.
There might be a little leakage every now and again.
Oopsie sorry,
I didn't know like a pipeline that passed down,
it was really fucked up was when that a giant BP spill went down that it really
like the,
the amount of devastation.
It was fairly mild in comparison to the amount of fucking oil that went into the
ocean.
Like it was an insane amount of oil.
It just kept getting pumped into the ocean.
But the amount of devastation,
like I thought it was going to be like half the ocean was dead.
Everything died.
And they were,
they were talking about it almost like it's stopped.
Like a lot of the different animals like shrimps,
like fuck them up hard and attracts ruined.
Like a lot of the fishing's bad.
Yeah,
they fucked up a lot of things.
No doubt about it.
And it fucks up a lot of people that cleaned it out.
But if you looked at it,
you wouldn't even know.
You're like,
you're,
you would drive over it.
We in your bone,
you'd be like,
yeah,
it looks like water.
That's the fucking water darker today.
We're all,
the shit went down.
It's like the ocean can figure out probably how to get rid of the oil better.
They can figure out how to get real as shit.
We pump on it to disperse the oil,
the,
oh the oceans in big trouble.
The oceans are truly and seriously fucked and that's,
reefs are like gone.
Coral reefs are in trouble.
And the,
the,
you know,
they,
they always,
everybody always talked about the Amazon where we're cutting down the Amazon and
it's the lungs of the earth creates all this oxygen.
The algae in the sea is more than double what the Amazon does and the ocean is
in trouble.
We really need to pay attention to that because it's at the core of the entire
global ecosystem and nobody's really paying much attention.
Well,
and not only that,
like we're watching it grow,
whether or not you believe global warming is caused by man,
whatever,
who knows?
I don't,
I'm not smart enough to understand that argument,
but when you watch the Greenland and watch these fucking giant Manhattan sized
chunks of ice falling into the ocean and you're like,
oh shit,
what is exactly going on here?
That's going to be a problem.
And when the,
uh,
a lot
of the ice melts,
it releases methane into the atmosphere,
which accelerates the process of global warming.
It's almost,
it's almost like a double edge sword.
It's really kind of fascinating.
I mean the,
the whole idea of this ebb and flow in the temperature of certain regions and
the earth itself,
it seems to just be a natural cycle.
It seems too,
besides the fact that human beings are affecting it and accelerating,
it seems to have always been this way.
It's really strange when you look back at like the ice age and know that half of
North America was covering a mile high sheet of ice just 13 14,000 years ago or
whatever it was like that is not very long ago.
Man.
Blink of an eye.
What we've done.
You're right.
It's fluctuated natural ear over eons,
but we've compressed the time for sure.
No,
we're certainly conti beasts worthy of scorn.
I love you talking about Cunty dinosaurs,
the
asteroid,
China and India are really,
really thoroughly ruining it quickly.
What are they doing?
Well,
they've got,
you know,
all of our manufacturing capability,
but with none of our gives a fuck about the environment.
Richard Nixon past the environmental protection agency.
I mean the law that he was the promoter of the law that created the
environmental protection agency.
Richard Nixon of all people,
but they don't have that in India.
They don't have that in China and so they're just gone back.
Somebody get them a Richard Nixon,
they need hope.
They need one badly.
So India and China,
they have no rules or they have less rules.
It's pretty West over there and you see a lot of pictures,
you know they'll do,
I'll see my friends go on press launches over there and stuff and it's like La
Smaug is fucking amateur hour compared to Beijing.
Smaug well I saw this one's fucked place in China.
They did a special on,
I forget who did the documentary,
but they said it was like smoking three packs of cigarettes a day.
Just breathing
the skies like literally a dark brown,
like the surgical masks.
That's horrific.
Entered operating procedure over there.
Oh,
weird.
Yeah.
What happens is too many people in one spot,
what went wrong with that?
You know,
shitty diesel engines.
Fucking two people still running two stroke scooters are maximizing their
maximizing the short term economic gain by not spending a little more money on
pollution.
That trolls.
But when we look at,
Oh my God,
that is insane.
These people drive.
Imagine that's every day.
It's incredible.
It's amazing.
They're alive.
But what's,
what's really crazy is how many of them there are.
Oh yeah.
You know when you find out that China has a billion people,
India has a billion people.
You're like,
oh my God,
how do you manage that?
It seems like it gets that bay,
it gets like way out of control.
Impossible.
That's what we really have to deal with in America.
Right?
We have to make sure that doesn't happen.
And what the fuck happens when we had a billion,
we get third world style.
Oh Dude.
Population growth is lower in developed countries.
Yes.
And they're saying that as the rest of the world catches up,
that population growth will
eventually be an issue in the negative way.
That's a theory.
But those theories don't mean Jack Shit.
Cause these mother fuckers would never put the empty the future ever.
No one's ever predicted the future ever.
That's one thing you can count on with people.
The future.
Good fucking luck figuring that shit out.
Right.
Cause that seemed like common sense though a little bit.
We have enough people that it's going to be a problem at some point.
That seems like common sense.
That seems more like common sense than what these people were saying that
eventually with the places become more and more populated and more advanced as
far as technology that people will start having less kids that'd be more
educated and just handle itself melted.
It'll just,
the idea is that they'll start having,
they'll start having careers if they started having careers they'll back off the
amount of children cause it'd be more opportunity and that the reason why these
people in these impoverished areas have children is because they don't have any
financial opportunities that they have kids.
It's,
I'm not sure I buy it now.
They don't think of it makes rational sociological sense.
If you have nothing and you have no prospects of having anything,
your best chance of surviving and getting something is to have a bunch of kids
and maybe one of them will get something and take care of you.
That's a weird gamble.
I don't think anybody gambles like that.
I don't think anybody will banks on 30 years from now,
my kid's going to be the shit that's going to be able to sit back on a yacht
because my kid bought me some cool shit.
I that's serious.
It's not about God.
It's about Hologic justice and a roof over your head at that time.
The way these work food,
I'm going to have a baby and wait for that baby to get me some food as well.
I think telling these ancient tribal cultures,
they did want you to have children because your children could contribute to the
household and take care of you when your old,
exactly.
You're Jewish.
Jewish culture is make more fucking Jews.
The Jews are all about making more Jews and the Mormons.
Mormons too.
It's like how do you grow the religion?
You either have lots of wives and lots of kids or you just have the,
I got that as a group of people that don't take the religion too seriously.
Jewel Jews dominate.
Oh yeah.
It's done.
Reformed Jews,
levels of Jew.
They're exactly the sitter themselves.
Jews can be cool and rational and normal and somehow Jewish.
Thank you Joe.
Thanks true.
Whereas Catholics,
good fucking luck.
Every time I meet a grown man that tells me as a Catholic,
I'm like this dude.
It's crazy.
You're crazy.
What are you doing?
Crazy?
My friend was die hard Catholic and her dad was die hard Catholic until one day
he woke up gay and left the family and moved in with his boyfriend and now good
thing Catholicism worked well.
I think two people were silly and I think that you know,
there's the,
the beautiful thing about Catholic church entirely is the community,
the sense of community.
Nobody getting together and agreeing to not be a Douche bag for a day.
That's a,
that's a beautiful sentiment.
But everything else that it's wrapped up in,
it's a group of kid fuckers,
a crazy cult of kid fuckers.
He dressed like wizards.
It's complete total chaos.
Pope is coming around,
the new pump doesn't care.
People are gay.
Gay.
He was talking about gay priests.
He's like,
who am I to judge did for last Jews?
But did you know that if you follow the pope,
here's The d refute that.
Not to say that that wasn't a great quote by him,
but here's where it goes in the toilet.
He said that if you follow him on Twitter,
you get less time in purgatory.
I shit you not even if you're a Jew,
shit you not.
What if,
listen,
if you're a Jew,
you know that you live in a fake religion.
Okay?
You know that you guys have created this.
He came out of Catholicism.
They would have something,
some rationalization,
like you have to do it fake forth Judaism.
You have to join Christianity and admit Jesus Christ.
Take him into your soul and heart and then you'll be saved.
You know what's weird?
People?
Jews did that for a lot of years.
There's a whole weird group of Jewish ancestors in New Mexico who were Spanish
and they stopped being Jews became Catholics so they could escape to the new
world.
Wow.
Got to New Mexico and they practice their Judaism in secret.
That's,
no,
no.
This is the real secret.
This is,
this is like what's going back to like the 16th century,
you know?
I'm never one to tell anybody what is and isn't real,
because the whole thing is pretty sketchy.
Who knows?
But wall,
all I care about with religious peoples',
if that,
if they really do adhere to the principles,
the religious doctrines,
they're usually pretty nice people if they,
you know,
I mean it's not,
it's not 100%,
but the people that are trying to use it as like a tool box,
trying to use it as like a way to get your life be good people more.
I don't think there's anything wrong with that.
No,
no,
not at all.
I'm not anti religion for other people.
But you call yourself a Catholic.
You most likely a silly batch.
Me Now.
Not that anybody does.
I said if you,
you,
oh my God,
Todd,
sorry.
More Ex.
Just people then religious people.
Oh,
of course.
Yeah.
Well you know,
it's,
it,
it's never that.
There's no god.
It's just that you look at any fucking story than anybody's ever told them about
anything.
And it's too hard to tell what the fuck really happened.
Right.
So hard to tell.
It's just a story.
It's so hard to tell,
like let's go back,
go back to the JFK assassination.
That shit was 1963 right.
Okay.
No one knows what happened.
We have a couple of videos.
There's a lot of different stories about what went down,
who was shooting at who and what they did to the body and the autopsy.
That was just,
that was within a human lifetime.
Right?
You want to go 500 years without even writing
my God.
Things get sketchy.
Yeah,
and you don't have,
you don't have photos.
Yeah,
no photos.
Did you guys even right back then?
Oh yeah.
We used to get out animal skins,
so we remember what we learned today.
We made a new factory and scrolls from the fucking buffalo tablets who told me
about fertility.
They were crazy asshole.
Oh,
by the way,
that guy was white like,
yeah.
They would occasionally stumble on magic mushrooms and eat a fucking pile of
them cause they were starving to death and completely rewired their religion.
All right,
we've got to try it.
Let's take it back to square zero.
Okay.
Everything we said was bullshit.
All right.
We're going to make it simple.
I got 10 ideas.
They parted the fucking sea on the Kod trip.
Fucking star David flags.
Well,
you know,
Jerusalem scholars actually are entertaining the idea like legitimate scars are
entertaining.
The idea that Moses,
when he saw the burning Bush was experiencing a psychedelic trip.
That makes sense.
That's the shopping sense religion,
religious statement ever made.
They even connected it to the Acacia Bush,
which is a very famous Bush,
a common Bush and that area that it is very rich and dimethyl trip to me really?
So this Bush could have potentially been dried out,
caught on fire huffing.
He's huffing to smoke and he experiences God.
It's very possible that that makes sense.
I mean,
why else would it be a burning Bush?
What's the Bush?
It's on fire and it's God,
Duh.
Okay.
I mean how much more they have to spell it out for you?
Most of these was a fucking drug and they only had 10 words back then.
They were doing their best.
That really does make sense.
It's totally logical explanation of religion and the history and what's logical.
That is not coming from people like me.
It's calming from a legitimate scholars,
which makes it fascinating is that they're considering the sources and the when
you know what the sources,
okay.
If you take you,
you trying to figure out what could have possibly caused this extraordinary
event that made them write this down,
while why would not you consider psychedelics?
Because it was really obvious that they worshiped a lot of different foods.
It was obvious they had like the ancient India,
they had mana and people had,
uh,
there was,
there was all sorts of different things.
So Ma,
which was supposed to be the greatest of all the psychedelics that the ancient
Hindus talked about.
Nobody even knows what the Fuck Soma is now.
It's just a shitty pill.
You buy it.
Yeah.
Well it's,
it's a sleeping pill.
Now this is interesting,
but the original Soma for was some sort of a competent Tory psychedelic brew
that might have involved more than one different type of psychedelic and it was
the shit to these people.
They worshiped it.
Why wouldn't they?
Of course they would.
Of course they have.
For the longest time,
people were afraid to say it.
people were afraid to say,
right,
but now scours are accepting it as a reality.
They're like,
look,
we know the effects of these chemicals.
Let's stop pretending we don't know the effects of these chemicals.
And then what's consider,
were they in the area?
Oh yes they were.
And they were in bushes.
What happened to those bushes?
Catching on fire?
Well,
I guess it would release that chemical,
wouldn't it?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I mean it's not like extracting.
Haven't been there.
Never been to Israel.
Now it's,
there's too much shit blowing up over there.
Nah,
Israel is pretty safe.
If you say that.
It's an unbelievable,
you're all Jude out.
If you're a Jew,
they'll give you a trip.
I'm saying think about how many other religions are there though,
right?
The Muslim religion comes from there.
Yeah.
It's a weird place.
Oh,
well I'm sure he comes from there too,
buddy.
So was Elvis.
But it's,
it's absolutely fascinating that that part of the world,
um,
which still constantly a conflict,
like two dogs barking at each other across fences.
I mean it's like in a constant conflict in that area.
Israel's pretty soon they said they were going to resume piece stocks,
Israel or Palestine,
they should get their shit together.
John Kerry,
secretary of state is really on it.
That's beautiful.
Really serious about it and he's making some progress.
It would be sweet to happen.
That would be beautiful.
You know,
people need to realize at some point in time that you don't have a problem with
anybody over there.
This groups of people that believe they have problems with other groups of
people and most of it's bullshit.
Right.
Most of it is a lack of understanding,
communication,
being affiliated with a group that you don't really want to be affiliated with
getting lumped into this fucking group of people by birth.
Yeah,
it's curfew leave like two people by themselves in a room.
They'll probably get along when really most likely.
Yeah.
We use the podcast a analogy all the time.
Like we had this Guy Dan Carlin on the other day and it was me and Brian and
Jamie and Dan Carlin.
Like,
if we were on an island together,
we would have zero fights.
Right?
Like what will we argue about it?
We never have a war.
Everything it'd be,
we'd find out where the food is.
We'd split it up.
We figured out how to grow shit.
We would work it out,
you know?
But when you get too many God damn people like,
Hey,
you know,
it was just too many fucking egos.
It's too many ideas to other points of view are selfish.
When you get beyond like four people competition,
they can be or they cannot be.
It's possible to not be too,
but you got to really like act out.
That's gotta be an f.
Well,
no I don't.
I don't,
I mean on an individual level they can do,
they cannot be,
but someone's going to be selfish if you have more than four people.
Well,
when you don't,
when you lose your accountability,
when you can like blend in the crowd of anonymous people and just driving around
in your car and just be a country Shithead,
you know?
It's like that's when things changes the equation.
Yeah.
When you moved to la?
Well,
I think,
um,
I think that it does change the equation though.
I think one of the things,
the reasons why people give each other the finger in cars is because they're
detached from me.
Trying to feel like whoever gives you the finger when you're walking,
no money.
There's no accountability.
Because if you look at,
let's consider a casino.
Have you ever gotten the finger given to you?
I'm going to casino.
No.
It's always,
excuse me.
Sorry.
He would just move in,
thrown and trying to get out of the way.
I've,
you know,
I mean,
you occasionally see a drunk and fight if you stay there late enough for the
month,
if you're lucky,
if you're lucky and you're in the right spot.
I love fucking Sharky's in Manhattan.
In Hermosa Beach,
that's where you're getting to fight.
But 99.9999% of the time when you're walking through a large group of people,
like in a mall,
right?
Something like that.
Everybody's cool with each other.
Yeah.
It's called.
We feel each other.
When you're a car,
you have,
fuck you.
It's like this weird thing.
You've got the capsule protection.
Yeah.
You gotta fucking box there.
You're good to go.
I've had people yell at me in the car before.
And which car did any of them really car?
Yeah,
over all the years.
I mean it's not often,
but when it does happen,
the rare time it does happen,
you're like,
whoa,
crazy charged up.
Mother Fucker is screaming at people in traffic.
No,
Michael Douglas on you one step up from a youtube comment or I had a guy take
off his shirt once,
took off his shirt to show me the sat twos in is start yelling at me.
He's the only man.
Okay.
First of all,
I know when I drive drive like a dick.
There have been times that I was guilty.
I am not a major deck,
but occasionally the person will make an aggressive maneuver that wasn't
recommended.
Okay.
That said,
I'm very friendly.
I wave.
I'm not,
I won't,
I won't do any douche moves.
Okay.
I'm not trying to be,
but this guy,
for whatever reason,
just decided that he wanted to get in front of me and that I didn't let him
quick enough.
Okay.
It was weird,
like the guy who went crazy,
like it was one of those like we're nothing really happened.
Right.
It was like,
you know,
I'm just trying to figure out how he's going to merge.
I'm looking back,
I'm looking to my left,
should I change lanes here and just let this guy in all the way.
And you know when I back off by the time he got beside me,
so fuck you,
fuck you and I,
and I'm like,
what happened?
And he goes,
you want to let me in you fucking piece of shit.
It was like,
oh my God.
And then he takes his shirt off and he shows me his tattoos and I was like,
this is the craziest thing.
There was a swastika on there.
So many,
oh no,
he had like a lot of tattoos and I just saw,
I just go,
you have really nice tattoos and I just bravo.
I gave him like zero aggression back.
I was like,
you're really nice tattoos and,
but he was like,
just like at highway speeds,
the traffic streets.
It's long time ago.
This is 1990 ish.
I'll never forget that Kat.
It says,
I'm like though that guy was just sad.
Bad for the guy might have stabbed me.
Like if I got out of the car,
that guy might have stabbed me.
I mean,
you never know.
That's the type of person that would fucking hit you with a crowbar.
You think you're fucking bad ass.
What is this?
Is this expendables and what is this?
Why are you showing this channel filling cool from Bollywood?
It's pretty sweet to go along with your story.
He just stepped out of a spinning kind of look like Stallone for a minute.
This is not,
go with my story.
Jamie,
stop this.
This is distracting.
Video mixing.
Rolling Mahindra SUV is,
is it bad that I can identify that?
No,
no.
That's an impressive company.
Why are you showing this man,
that's impressive.
I would have no idea what kind of car that was.
The Mahindra.
He knew it's a Bali.
You know how Bollywood cars are,
you know what they are?
I mean you can name that particular Indian vehicle.
How many different vehicles?
They have an Indian,
but they have like unique,
like a sports cars and Chili Fan.
Not Sports House.
No.
Now they import the sports cars in India they have like tuck talks and Todd Todd
nanos and Mahindra cars.
Like what's a Tuck Tuck?
It's like a three wheeled thing with a small motorcycle engine.
Power t u k talk,
talk,
Tuck,
tuck.
Two horsepower engine.
Like a guy in the WIC.
Tiny.
It's like a taxi and Mumbai and other places in and a family all are in a school
bus.
Right,
and a camel lead vehicle.
Everything.
Yeah.
Look at that and talk.
Talk.
No,
that's not a,
that's a,
that's a Rolls Royce of Tuck.
Tuck,
tuck.
Actually,
I'm not kidding you.
It's on chrome.
So it's essentially they realize,
hey look,
we don't really need a car.
Yeah,
it's warm out.
We just need something that's going to keep bill have fastest way to get shit
from one place to another.
That's all around asking people on a moped over there.
I mean they're crazy family of 19 and again,
is that because there's so many of them,
is that what happens when you get so many people and they stuffed him in this
one,
not enough space?
Is that just what we'd lose value and everyone's just to fucking wild animal.
Oh yeah.
It's just the way it is.
I mean that'll,
that'll grow and change.
India's growing and changing.
It's an amazing country.
Have you seen the,
I sound like such a liberal,
it sounded as you seen guilty.
I know.
Have you seen the videos of a Chinese people driving in like random videos from
Chinese streets where they just take turns into traffic?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
A friend tried to explain it to me,
this is non racist.
This is just a sociological and cultural.
He said Chinese people,
most most of them as they're walking down the street,
they're very polite.
They don't mind other people's business and they look straight ahead and they
don't look to the left hand,
don't look to the right.
And if they bump into each other,
they don't worry about it and they keep walking and it's normal.
So the,
the type of behavior required to drive an automobile is completely different.
You have to think completely different than your normal mode of transportation.
Your normal mode is your legs.
And when you do that,
you're,
you have a very specific way of looking at the world,
but you have to open wide when you drive a car.
And some of them just are not buying it.
So they just driving straight through intersections.
When he said this,
I,
you know,
like,
cause he was talking about,
well he was talking about the reasons for stereotypes,
right?
He's like,
what are the reasons for certain stereotypes?
He goes,
well,
they're all,
almost all of them are based on something that makes sense.
Otherwise people wouldn't agree to them.
It may hurt people's feelings and they may be racist,
but let's try to find the root of it.
And so he was trying to find the root of Asian driving and he was like,
it's very clear.
It's like they're,
it's,
they're being humble and you know,
not drawing attention to themselves and not worrying about bumping into each
other at the other end of the spectrum.
Have you seen,
I mean like the crazy Arab drifting?
Yes.
Hog Wallah on two wheels changing a tire and I want to do a series here in the
states called Formula Hug Wallah where we actually had,
and they have to wear the gowns,
but they look like NASCAR it out with the sponsors and shit.
That's harder energy.
Fucking hug Wallah,
you know.
And they have no guard rails.
You know,
you have oncoming traffic of course somebody,
some poor bastard.
That's the sign up for that shit.
They got to wear a turban though.
And Marlboro just hog Walla into traffic to the of thousands.
If you even put that Marlboro turban down on paper and they'll fuck,
here we go.
Look at these fucking guys here guys.
So we'll,
that's a dye hotsy rocky at 90 miles an hour,
right?
Something,
I mean,
I don't know.
Can't be 90 35 or 40 it's scary enough to scare the fuck out of you because if
that guy comes down,
that wheel is in back on,
he's fucked.
I keep that driving.
Essentially it's half an hour changing a fucking wheel.
The road goes straight
all the way across the desert.
This guy's changing a fuck and have you seen the road?
The road skating?
Oh my God.
Look at this.
He took the wheel off and they're staring at it.
Yeah,
he's got,
they're getting,
are they going to try to put that wheel back on other switching?
Yes.
Okay.
How could you possibly put a wheel on why the car is going that fast and that's
the driver is only two wheels on the road.
Yeah,
but it doesn't matter.
Your actual spinning.
How are you going to connect it to the accidents there?
Free wheeling the eye.
It's not a live axle.
Yeah,
they're independent suspension so that the axle without the wheel isn't
spinning,
but he has a back wheels off too.
It has open differentials open with us with an open differentially by God.
That is insane.
The vehicle is,
would be lightly prepped for this test very lightly,
right?
I mean,
they opened differential.
Oh my God.
Look at this guy hanging out the bottom of this.
This guy is insane.
The Guy Inside is handling some serious fucking pressure.
Matt did this with a Hertz rental car.
People die doing this shit.
No joke.
People actually really die doing this to stop all the time.
Oh no joke.
Come on.
Of course they died.
He's driving while he's hanging out the window and he's on two.
We see that.
You see the road skating.
Look up Saudi road skating.
They,
they skate.
It's unbelievable ways in sandals.
Those people are crazy.
Yes.
What they have nothing else to do with their time.
Is that what it is or they just gangster?
No,
they have all the money in the world and all the oil in the world.
What else are you going to do and all the sandals in the world here.
Look here.
Look at these guys.
Skating in sandals on the highway.
That is inside of a,
what looks like a Hyundai Elantra.
They climb out and climb back in.
Oh my God.
That is insane.
Look at them.
Hang backwards.
Oh my God.
Like in traffic.
He's hanging backwards break.
He's just stepping out there.
This is so insane.
I have never seen anything this.
And so my God chose mine.
Sloan.
Right.
Silly counties are those just street scandal.
Looking at the,
look at him hanging out the door right there.
I like that.
These guys are standing on the tarmac.
It's one,
one foot up in the air as the move.
This is so crazy.
Oh my God.
I'm shitting my pants.
Oh,
it's great fun.
I feel like we're encouraging something awful by playing this.
Don't do this at home kids.
Please don't do that at home.
It's already been done.
It's on youtube.
Go enjoy it.
You'll die doing that.
Probably way too dangerous podcast is over.
Yeah.
That's basically three hours we did it.
Um,
thank you Matt Farah.
That was a lot of fun,
dude.
We got a little lit up.
Tell some stories.
Good Times.
Good Times with my friend.
And a,
you can catch Matt Online at,
uh,
the smoking tire on Twitter.
All one word.
And,
uh,
what's your website?
The smoking,
tire.com smoking tire.com is a bunch of shit that he has on youtube on the drive
network.
And you could find it online.
It's like all on youtube,
right.
Lots of youtube views.
Yeah.
And you also had the old stuff is all the smoking tire.
Right.
That's current to there.
Boom,
boom.
Get them on both.
Yeah.
Drive in the smoking tire.
So,
um,
all your shit can be found.
All the things you've done on a,
on Youtube.
Fun stuff to keep.
Keep doing it.
I really enjoy it.
Thanks man.
You did one of them when you had a bad back and you had another guy drive.
I liked that one.
That was fun day before I had surgery.
That's challenge.
Yeah.
It and you also did it with the um,
uh,
an Audi that are a r eight.
Vito is,
I had a fucking torn ACL.
Oh Wow.
Oh,
my substitute was,
I hired a substitute that day.
He's now the editor of motor trend coming is you become the editor after that.
He was great.
Yeah.
He could do his own videos too.
It's a broad market.
Beautiful.
Follows him to you.
Fucks.
Um,
thanks to legal zoom.com,
uh,
use a code name,
Rogan,
and save yourself some money from legal zoom.
Thanks.
Also to,
uh,
who do we have today?
Audible,
audible.com.
That's it.
Um,
audible.com,
the number one provider of audio entertainment as far as audio books and
podcasts and radio shows on the online,
more than a hundred thousand things to download a,
if you use a code named Brogan,
oh,
go to audible.com,
forward slash Joe rather.
That's audible.com.
Forward Slash Joe,
you can get one free audio book and 30 free days of audible service.
Try it.
You'll enjoy the shit out of it.
And uh,
on at.com,
that's o nit.
Use the code name,
Rogan and save 10% off.
All right.
That's it.
Wait,
it's fucking things.
Oh wait,
wait.
But Todd [inaudible] dot com.
Oh yeah,
we,
I have a TV show,
Joe Rogan questions,
everything.
I forgot about that.
Yeah,
that's Wednesday night.
10:00 PM is a,
yeah,
this one is a Wednesday night,
10:00 PM we,
uh,
we look at chem trails and weaponize weather.
Very interesting stuff.
Sounds good.
Enjoy the shit out.
It freaks and,
um,
that's it.
We will see you on Friday again on the podcast with Jimmy Norton and,
uh,
that's it.
We Love Ya.
Thanks everybody.
Big Kiss.
Thanks Joe and Tom Mesereau.
Alright.
Hello.
Great.
Was that three hours
35 at night?
That was fun.